яка говорить сама за себе Ми підводимо
підсумки нашого проекту за 5 років і
наразі ми розпочинаємо нашу конференцію
Мене звати Дмитро семенистий як комуніка
експерт-проекту і буде вести сьогодні
цей захід але спочатку озвучу декілька
аргументів і потім перейдемо до програми
Якщо вам потрібно було у нас будуть
презентації англійської мови якщо вам
потрібні навушники ви можете їх взяти от
в тому кутку
англомовній колеги є коли x-fone тільки
Raining
і хочу нагадати про заходи безпеки якщо
буде оголошено повітряним тривога ми
маємо зупинити конференцію і спуститись
на мінус другий поверх у
підземний паркінг ми маємо вийти через
основний вхід і спуститись або сходами
або ліфтом тож коротко наша програма Ми
спочатку почуємо вітальні слова від
представників наших донорів і партнерів
від Європейського Союзу та Міністерства
посольства Фінляндії в Україні і завдяки
яким наш проект і зробив свій вклад у
реформу освіти і з вітальним словом ви
ступить представник Міністерства освіти
і науки України
наш основний партнер завдяки якому ми
якого ми з самого початку і підтримували
далі
результати проекту представлять ярко
лампіселька та керівник проекту та Роман
Шиян національний директор проекту після
цього виступить Юрій завалевський перший
заступник директора інституту інституту
модернізації змісту освіти І після нього
виступить
Вибачте після нього виступить Василь
Терещенко далі у нас буде обідня перерва
з 13-ї години і після обідньої перерви
нас будуть дискусійні панелі перша буде
стосуватися мовної освіти і викладання
та вивчення української мови друга буде
присвячена питанням освітнього
середовища та освітнього контенту потім
кава пауза і
дискусійна панель з питань професійного
розвитку та підготовки вчителів після
цього буде презентація з практичними
комунікаційним продуктами для освітян і
остання дискусійна панель підтримка
партнерів під час реалізації реформи нуш
Як будемо дарувати Роман Шиян буде
включати представників різних
міжнародних організацій які підтримували
нуш і приблизно 17 буде фінальна секція
під час якої виступить пан Андрій
Сташків заступник міністра освіти і
науки України який скаже підсумкову
промову А зараз у нас є приємний сюрприз
у виконанні хору старшої школи імені
уса міста Гельсінки вони записали гімн
України українською мовою тож колеги
прошу
не
бо
тихих міста
горілка успіхнеться
[музика]
твоя
краса
сонце запалює
віночка у своїй
[музика]
сторонці
друже диво
природи життя
нашу свободу
бажаний
[музика]
брат козацького роду
подачі за
[музика]
Господи
покажи що мій браття козацького
роду
[музика]
Дякуємо
в школі середньої школи іменіуса А перед
тим як передати пану Андрію Сташків
слово Я трохи скажу про наш проект
навчаємось разом стартував у 18-му році
і є проекти міжнародної співпраці що
фінансується міністерством закордонних
справ Фінляндії та Європейським Союзом і
має національне охоплення і орієнтований
на підтримку нової української школи На
цьому я передаю слово пану Андрію прошу
Дякую пане Дмитро зона денне слово
Добрий день шановні Учасники конференції
надзвичайно ради вітати вас в такій
неформальній обстановці яку ми всі тут
бачимо і дуже символічно що цей захід
відкриває саме фінський хор і саме
гімном України адже такий проект який ми
сьогодні на жаль підсумовуємо
є реалізований завдяки підтримки
підтримці уряду Фінляндії
реформа нової української школи почалися
ще в далекому 2018 році і стала чи не
найуспішнішою реформою у сфері освіти
яка взагалі відбулася в Україні і мені
надзвичайно приємно що серед нас є
Міністерка освіти і науки України Лілія
Михайлівна Гриневич саме завдяки якій
починалася ця реформа нової української
школи
адже це показує ту наслідність і той
суспільний договір про який говорила
Ліна михайльної освіти що незалежно ні
від чого реформа має продовжуватись у
світі адже вона триває не рік і Не два а
дуже довго і потребує підтримки всіх
урядів і і влада яка є в Україні
реформа стартувала і уже можна підбивати
певні підсумки цей реформи але
стартувала вона також завдяки підтримці
саме цього проекту навчаємося разом Я
хочу висловити вдячність від імені
Міністерства освіти і науки України
уряду Фінляндії а також Європейському
Союзу за підтримку цієї реформи адже 8
мільйонів євро які в свій час були якби
вкладені в реформу і підтримку цієї
реформи є важливими для впровадження
цієї реформи так в межах цього проекту
були проведені велика кількість
тренінгів
семінарів онлайн-курсів для вчителів
директорів шкіл що значно підвищило
професійний розвиток наших вчителів
окремо хочу відзначити комунікаційні
компанії які були проведені в рамках
проекту саме завдяки комунікації реформа
нової української школи як показує дані
опитування є відомою і про неї знають як
вчителі так і батьки такі учні що значно
якби підсилює можливості проведення цієї
реформи окремо хочу подякувати також
проекту за допомогою в друзі підручників
адже ви знаєте що минулий рік коли
почалася військова агресія Росії проти
України бюджет був надзвичайно малий і
нова українська школа в п'ятий класах На
жаль
розпочалися без тих підручників які були
заплановані надрукувати і завдяки
фінському проекту 360 тисяч підручників
з природничої галузі на даний момент
надруковані і вже з 1 вересня будуть в
школі так перед Україною зараз суттєві
виклики і та військова агресія значно
ускладнює реалізацію реформи як я вже
казав підручники не були надруковані про
це не було
надана субвенція де підтримки нової
української школи але ми зараз працюємо
над тим щоб відновити цю пенсію щоби
надрукувати всі підручники завдяки
коштам який є в державному бюджеті а
також коштами е надані нам міжнародними
донорами та партнерами тому я впевнений
що реформа української нової української
школи завершиться успішно тоді коли вона
має завершитись 2030 році Ми всі будемо
ще не раз зустрічатися підбивати
підсумки цієї реформи Міністерство свого
боку зробить все для того щоб підтримати
щоби впровадити цю реформу на належному
рівні вже цього року ми відновимо
субвенцію на нову українську школу в
тому числі для наших пілотних шкіл
минулий рік без навчальних матеріалів я
уявляю як вам всім було складно
реалізовувати цю реформу Тому цього року
вона точно буде це субвенція і точно Ви
отримуєте навчальні матеріали проте як
буде продовжуватися реформа я розкажу в
заключному своєму слові як ми будемо її
реалізовувати в другому циклі базової
середньої освіти А також про старшу
профільну школу а всім вам я Бажаю
гарно провести час отримати нові емоції
нові знання і Всім дякую
Дякуємо пане Андрій так дійсно
підручники завдяки нашим донорам ми
надрукували Ось вони ви можете
ознайомитись побачити їх А зараз я
передаю слово п Мартіну шредеру з
представництва ЄС в Україні який є
керівником відділу місцевого та
людського розвитку які виступить онлайн
пане Мартін до ефір АС
шановне учасники
ми не дуже приємно бути цього не з вами
трохи шкодую що це інше онлайн
від імені Європейського Союзу Я хочу
питати вас на цій події і навіть якщо це
заключний захист проєкту я сприймаю його
як хочеш таток обговорення майбутнього
можливості для України
На жаль власне майбутнє України та
освіта України зазнали нападу з боку
Росії із 2016 року
діти деякі діти змушені навіть навчатися
у школах російською якщо вони живуть на
непідконтрольних уряду території дуже
багато дітей змушені були покинути свою
домівку переїхати чи буде переміщеними
до інших територій але дуже багато дітей
хочуть продовжувати навчатися і
незважаючи на усі виклики освітяни
продовжують навчати тому я хотів би
зараз скористатися цією можливістю і
висловити свою повагу тим хто віддано
продовжує забезпечувати освітній процес
тим хто навчає та навчається по суті Під
вогнем артилерія Спасибі велике за усю
вашу роботу і ми пишаємося тим що ми
стали частиною цієї боротьби
що стосується Європейського Союзу
Перепрошую Ми чуємо розмови у мікрофон у
залі Отож я пишаюся тим що ми правильно
розставили пріоритети і представники
Європейського Союзу відкрили свої серця
та двері своїх шкіл для українських
дітей щоб ті продовжили освіту більше як
750 тисяч
дітей із України наразі навчаються у
школах Європейського Союзу
навчаємось разом такий таке гасло нашого
проекту і зараз справді українські діти
навчають це спільно і з своїми
однолітками і у той час ми виділяємо
мільйони доларів та євро на те щоб діти
навчалися в Україні разом із своїми
однолітками Ми також намагаємося
надавати психологічну підтримку як учням
так і вчителям намагаємося дещо
переформатувати підтримку для тих дітей
у котрих немає батьків немає
батьківської опіки і котрі потребують
особливого підходу до свого навчання Ми
підтримуємо Міністерство освіти та науки
України
сформувавши відповідну команду підтримки
реформ Петра налічує більше як 20 людей
також намагаємось зробити свій внесок у
покращення
професійно-технічної освіти знову ж таки
усі зусилля в рамках плюс програми і ми
намагалися зробити все можливе для того
щоб підтримати навчаємося разом проект
котрий було ініційовано Фінляндію і таке
успішне завершення котрого ми святкуємо
Сьогодні знову ж таки надавалося все
можлива підтримка задля того щоби
якнайкраще впроваджувати реформу нова
українська школа нуш і я хотів би
подякувати усій команді за їхню невпинно
роботу і знову ж таки у дуже складних
умовах з котрими Ми зіштовхнулися
сьогодні у вас буде можливість
обговорити в деталях дії результати
досягнення і впровадження реформи як
такої Я впевнений що рекомендації
методології котрі були
продуктом такої нашої діяльності
продовжуватимуть підтримувати реформу
нуш задля того щоб виграла кожна дитина
України і Дозвольте завершити також
словами про майбутнє майже от рівно один
рік тому Україна стала
офіційною Україною членом
кандидаткою на члену Європейському Союзі
І власне сподіваємось Україна дуже
швидко долучиться Вже офіційно до
Європейського Союзу Дуже дякую від себе
та від Європейського Союзу чудового
заходу
Щиро дякуємо мартіне слово голові голові
міжнародного співробітництва та питання
освіти посольства Фінляндії пані
міні-харайнин прошу
Шановний пане заступник Міністра любі
партнери освітяни
для мене справжня честь бути тут і з
вами сьогодні від імені посольства
Фінляндії у Києві
розпочати
подякувавши Міністерство освіти та науки
і теперішньому міністрові колишній
міністрці і усім експертам за таку
тривалу співпрацю в рамках життя нашого
проекту Я також хотіла подякувати
представнику Європейського Союзу то те
що повірили в нас за те що долучилися до
наших зусиль з приводу реалізації
реформи нуш я справді сподіваюся що це
був всього лиш початок плідної співпраці
із Європейським Союзом з тим щоб
підтримати освітню галузь в Україні та
її розвиток
дуже багато чого було досягнуто з того
моменту коли було сформовано відповідно
консультативну групу
Фінляндії у 2018 році ми скоро почуємо в
деталях що до досягнень проекту
навчаємося разом з уст пана Романа шияна
та пана ярко лампісельки і я хотіла б
тільки зазначити одну річ
незважаючи на пандемію ковід-19
незважаючи на невиправдано російську
агресію в Україні проект навчаємось
разом залишався вірним своїм ключовим
завданням А це надавати підтримку мон
надавати підтримку освітянам та сприяти
тому щоби реформа нуш тривала проект
підтримав реалізацію реформи багатьма
способами проводячи тренінги для
директорів вчил та
вона вчителів впроваджуючи відповідні
інструменти розробки освітніх програм
друком підручників підтримуючи
викладання української мови
у школах де мова викладання є відмінною
від української і це ще невичерпний
перелік Минулого року проект те що
переорієнтував свою діяльність і бюджет
зважаючи на потреби Для прикладу як уже
зазначалося
заступником міністра проект
профінансував друк більш як
360 тисяч підручників забезпечує
психосоціальну підтримку дітей і
Сьогодні ці підручники вже готові до
того щоб їх передали школам і чекають
знову ж таки на те щоб у руки їх взяли
учні коли почнеться новий навчальний рік
любі друзі в рамках проекту навчаємося
разом фінські експерти ділилися своїми
напрацюваннями підходами практичними
аспектами порадами як ото оцінювання
навчання тощо і в Фінляндія знову ж таки
з самого початку реформи нуш почала
надавати свою підтримку і наша
національна історія успіху це історія
бідної країни післявоєнної країни Котра
боролася із радянським союзом за своє
виживання і нарешті змогла вирвати
мирний договір
і Фінн у корелії втратили свої домівки
їх було перед заслоковано переселено в
інші частини України і вони складали 11%
населення Фінляндії у ті часи дуже
багато фінів включаючи мене
все ще мають батьків дідусів бабусів
котрі втратили свої домівки на кордоні
із радянським союзом тоді коли кордон
було переглянуто і історія успіху
Фінляндії включає два важливих елементи
котрі варті нашої уваги перше
це
їжа у школах
це дуже важливий елемент безкоштовні
обіди у школах допомогли неабияким чином
у Фінляндії трансформуватися у
суспільство орієнтоване на знання
коли було прийнято закон про безкоштовну
їжу безкоштовні обіди у школах пісні ще
дозволили нам подолати питання
недоїдання У після
воєнні роки і завдяки закону уряд
забезпечує що щонайменш одна тепла їжа
для одного школяра чи школярки були
доступні на день це знизило економічне
навантаження на 7 є і підвищило
статус в готовності дітей ще один
важливий Фактор котрий повпливав на
успіх Фінляндії
виник на початку 70-х років коли два
регіони у Фінляндії почали впроваджувати
революційний
революційно-шкільну реформу
загальноосвітню шкільну реформу і дещо
змінили погляд на освіту дуже важливо
зазначити що це були північні частини
Фінляндії котрі представляли найбільш
бідні регіони Фінляндії перед реформою
освітня система Фінляндія
характеризувалася соціально-економічною
нерівністю бідні сім'ї не могли
дозволити собі відправити своїх дітей до
тих шкіл котрі були більш академічно
орієнтованими І власне впровадження
загальноосвітньої обов'язкової освіти
змінило все це адже до цього Тільки дуже
мало дітей мали змогу переходити до
старшої школи чи продовжувати своє
навчання А
також власне усіх учнів оцінювали
відповідно до соціально-економічного
стану України і ми все ще можемо бачити
певні паралелі котрі стосуються
української освіти і власне
результати фіса показали деякий розрив в
Україні у навчанні та академічних
досягненнях 15-річних дітей з міста та
села і Можливо ви дивитесь чому я кажу
так багато про фінську реформу в той час
коли ми повинні святкувати досягнення
проекту навчаємось разом тому що я хочу
нагадати усім нам наскільки потужним
інструментом може стати реформа освіти
наскільки Вона може трансформувати
суспільство дуже багато викликів
Фінляндія подолала завдяки своїй реформі
І власне Україна зіштовхується
працівниками через війну рівень бідності
в Україні зростає а право дітей на
освіту Не завжди виконується нуш має
подібні
цілі як і реформа освіти у Фінляндії це
доступ до високоякісної освіти це
створення підґрунтя для майбутнього
успіху України
освіта була та залишається основною
сферою в рамках котрої Фінляндії надає
допомогу Україні в рамках нашої
співпраці більше того ми будемо
продовжувати і будемо навіть збільшувати
нашу підтримку освітній галузі в Україні
Отож
проекти котрі Фінляндія а підтримали і ю
фестки уста навчаємось разом добігають
кінця і Міністр закордонних справ
Фінляндії зазначив що буде продовжувати
надавати підтримку і наразі ми провели
консультації з рядом експертів у галузі
освіти у Фінляндії до України з тим щоб
зрозуміти де ще потрібна наша підтримка
у майбутньому і роль міністра освіти та
науки у цьому процесі є вкрай важливим і
я під'юджую мон продовжувати активно
залучатися до таких консультацій і
наважився сказати що так чи інакше ми
будемо продовжувати підтримувати реформу
нуш
любі друзі
зараз
поглянувши на минуле та на майбутнє я
хотіла повернути нас до тут Та зараз і
хотіла привітати
представників проекту навчаємося разом
котрі працювали невтомно з тим щоби цілі
нуш було досягнуто щоби власне усі
українці знали про них та підтримували
без команди проекту вчителі керівники
шкіл директори І власне розробка
навчальних матеріалів не були можливими
і насамкінець
як зазначено у документі підписаному та
європейською комісією і я цитую освіта у
серці європейського стилю життя і є
вкрай важливою для життя
демократії та розбудови економіки
Україна є частиною Європи і наразі
бореться за її незалежність Отож Україна
перебуває на своєму шляху до повного
членства Європейському Союзі Фінляндія
щиро вірить що реформа освіти і
впровадження реформи нуш допоможе
в Україні у її шляху до Європейського
долучення до сім'ї Європейського Союзу
та покращить добробут людей Дякую за
увагу а зараз у нас є дійсно спеціальна
гостя це перший проєкторка Київського
університету імені Грінченка Міністерка
освіти і науки України 16-19 років пані
Лілія Гриневич прошу
[оплески]
шановні пані та панове Шановні колеги я
дуже рада вас бачити Я рада бути тут і
от минуло 5 років добре пам'ятаю у липні
2018 року наш візит до Фінляндії і в
Міністерстві закордонних справ Фінляндії
відбувалося підписання угоди з приводу
розпочинання цього проєкту І я хочу
зараз висловити нашу велику вдячність
народу Фінляндії за те що Ви дали таку
серйозну допомогу Україні в підсиленні
реформи шкільної освіти і я пишаюся тим
що коли ми розпочинали реформу ми змогли
досягти домовленості про таку допомогу
саме Від Фінляндії тому що дуже гарно
Сьогодні ми чули в промові про те який
шлях критичний пройшла система освіти
Фінляндії але сьогодні Фінляндія на
перших позиціях у міжнародних
порівняльних дослідженнях сьогодні у
Фінляндії найменший розрив між
навчальними
досягненнями дітей з різних
соціально-економічних груп І загальний
середній рівень дуже високий сьогодні
Фінляндія продовжує робити шкільну
реформу я про це скажу трошки пізніше і
її досвід також дуже релевантний для
України Це не означає Я одразу хочу
сказати що це зовсім не означає що ми
хочемо імплементувати саме фінський
досвід тому що національні системи
шкільної освіти мають
надзвичайно сильну власну ідентичність і
в даному випадку ми говоримо про
експертну підтримку у виробленні власних
рішень тоді ми обрали 4
пріоритети першим пріоритетом вони
збігаються зрештою з пріоритетами
впровадження реформи нової української
школи перше - Це професійний розвиток
педагогів другий це потім стало
компонентами другий пріоритет - це
відповідно побудова нового навчального
безпечного середовища і третій чи другий
не має значення як вони можуть іти по
порядку всі вони дуже важливі це
популяризація освіти важливості освіти
та реформи нової української школи і я
дуже вдячна Європейському союзу і Пані
Вірі яка тут представляє власне
структури Європейського Союзу за те що
саме цьому проєкту був довірений мовний
компонент Справа в тому не знаючи ви
колеги пригадуєте Що сприйняттям закону
Про освіту 2017 року наша мовна стаття
вказувала про пріоритетність вивчення
державної мови і на той час національні
меншини в Україні мали неймовірно низькі
результати зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання з української мови так от
Саме цей мовний компонент зробив велику
роботу для того щоб з допомогою
канадських колег створити підручники які
мають той універсальний підхід і дизайн
який
сприймається представниками національних
меншин які мають іншу рідну мову ніж
українську і призводять до кращих
результатів вивчення державної мови
Я хотіла б сьогодні згадати тих
експертів які були поряд з нами впродовж
всіх цих років а саме ярко лампіселька
пасі
Вибачте якщо я неправильно сказала
пані туя лаурен і дуже дякую роману
шияну який був незмінним очільником
проєкту з української сторони і лідером
який вмів гнучко реагувати і
співпрацювати з фінськими колегами для
того щоб ми
при потребі
якимось чином координували проєкт
можливо на нові завдання Ми живемо в
буремні часи і моя окрема вдячність
нашим партнерам полягає за те що ви
гнучко реагували на наші потреби зараз
коли вибухнула повномасштабна війна
звісно появились нові виклики і знову
проєкт відреагував на ці потреби це для
нас неймовірно цінно
я хотіла зараз підкреслити що насправді
реформа нова українська школа опинилася
в дуже складних умовах зверніть увагу
наші діти початкової школи яке навчалось
за новими державними стандартами у ці
перші діти Ну поза пілотом вони
розпочали навчатися відповідно у 17-му
році і що сталося далі у 20-му році
розпочався ковід і Ці діти навчалися
дистанційно Я думаю що всі присутні
педагоги добре знають що дітям
початкової школи є шкідливим дистанційне
навчання і воно не дає достатньої
результативності при переході до п'ятого
класу вибухає війна і ці діти знову
продовжують в більшості навчатися
дистанційно Ми не можемо отримати
адекватні результати моніторингу
навчання за новим державним стандартом з
цієї причини що Ми не розуміємо скільки
років цих результатах впливу цього
вимушеного дистанційного навчання і це є
великий виклик який дуже часто може
демоти демотивувати Друга проблема що
коли діти переходили до навчання в
п'ятий клас не було і про це вже
сьогодні звучало звук заступника
міністра адекватної підтримки реформи
через війну
коли немає і вчителі не відчувають
цільового підвищення кваліфікації не
будується спільноти тренерів за
предметами так як це було в початковій
школі тому що ці спільноти тренерів
відповідно в кожному регіоні потім є
нашою точкою росту для нової української
школи або ж коли вчителі не бачать зміни
навчального середовища Для того щоб вони
могли впроваджувати оце
проблемно-пошукове дослідницьке навчання
і зараз
ситуація спричинила те що
вчителі-предметники не зовсім розуміють
по всій країні яким чином далі працювати
з дітьми тому до чого я говорю про
проблеми ми можемо сьогодні підбивати
підсумки і ми задоволені результатами
5-річної співпраці Але перед нами нові
виклики Які ще пов'язані з великими
навчальними втратами пов'язаними з
війною в деяких груп дітей ці навчальні
втрати так чи інакше
потрібно теж взяти до уваги при в
подальшому впровадженні реформи нова
українська школа
Мені здається що і я так щиро бажаю того
що сьогодні до кінця завершення цієї
заключної конференції Ми зрозуміли що
вона є заключною тільки для одного етапу
і перед нами наступна робота і нам
потрібна спів На завершення хочу просто
трошки для натхнення додати ще фінського
досвіду мені недавно довелося працювати
для організації економічної співпраці і
розвитку над проектом коли країни
діляться своїми виходами в освіті щодо
вирішення різних кризових ситуацій і
серед цього досвіду був досвід Фінляндії
в чому він полягав у 2021 році Фінляндія
запровадила обов'язкове навчання у
старшій профільній школі раніше воно
було опційне для дітей Зараз воно
обов'язково і вони провели дуже серйозне
економічне обґрунтування обов'язково
трирічного навчання бо це ж додаткові
кошти зрозуміло які треба дати на всіх
дітей і довели те що країна виграє від
три обов'язкової трирі старший
профільної школи в довготривалій
перспективі щодо зайнятості рівня освіти
населення і його продуктивності Тому це
теж надзвичайно цей досвід в руслі
нашого переходу до старшої трирічної
старшої профільної школи ще раз велика
вдячність усім усім колегам які
доклалися до реалізації цього проєкту і
сподіваємося на подальшу спільну успішну
дорогу дякую
[оплески]
Дякуємо пане Лілія зараз і за
результатами проекту виступить керівник
проекту навчаємось разом ярколем
пісенька який виступить онлайн
ярко до і hears
info
передаємо словами
міністра заступнику міністра Шановні
колеги
Я дуже щасливий бути сьогодні тут і з
вами на наші заключній конференції
проекту цей момент представляє для мене
кульмінацію наших спільних зусиль нашої
відданості нашої готовності досягати
прогресу поступу у освіті і коли я
озираюся на нашу подорож я дуже вдячний
усім і кожному із вас Хто брав участь у
цьому проекті не тільки тим хто працював
безпосередньо У проекті але усім тим
вчителям директорам інституційним
лідерам котрі активно брали участь у
проекті
і ми подолали з вами багатобар'єрі ми
подолали багато кордонів І ми провадили
довготривалий вплив позитивний вплив на
освіту і наша віра у співпрацю усталий
розвиток
провела нас через усі виклики та
труднощі і наразі ми наближаємося до
завершення настільки успішного проекту і
в рамках цього проекту ми досягли
значних досягнень ми змінили життя
і покращили навчання учнів
і зараз ми підбиваємо підсумок
давайте відсвяткуємо наші досягнення ті
уроки котрих нами було засвоєно
паче Шановні колеги
Шановні пане міністра заступнику
міністра наша відповідальність тут не
завершується
ми власне
маємо на наших ключах відповідальність
переконатися що нами буде забезпечено
сталість результатів Отож як ми чули
проект тривав п'ять років Ми розпочали у
та продовжували аж до 2023 року і я
хочу щиро зазначити що я вдячним нашим
донорам Міністерство закордонних справ
Фінляндії представництво Європейського
союзу в Україні за вашу підтримку без
ваших зусиль ми б не змогли провадити
проект от наскільки потужно та у такому
масштабі Отож цілі проекту цілі проекту
було націлено на три сфери
Отож сфера один з концентрована
переважно на професійному розвитку
вчителів
і друга на
об'єзнаності щодо реформи нової
української школи та покращення рівня
такої поінформованості про цю реформу і
третя сфера сконцентровувалася на
навчальному середовищі котре у нашому
випадку
означало
розробку навчальних матеріалів
системи і Learning також тренінги для
директорів шкіл і проект мав дуже
рідкісну можливість бути імплементованим
на настільки масштабному рівні в галузі
освіти і цільові групи дійсно коливалися
від вчителів
від тих хто розробляє підручники до
учнів до представників навіть
Міністерства і нами будуть організовано
багато тренінгів для цільових груп і
дуже були різноманітні заходи теми
тренінгів дійсно десятки різноманітних
тренінгів було з організовано і тисячі
директорів та вчителів пройшли такі
тренінги і проекти розробив цілий
ряд як цих прових продуктів так і
друкованих підручників і дуже багато
відповідних інших матеріалів
технічна проблема мабуть на стороні пана
Ярка
можливо
пан Шиян ви можете доповнити
і ми намагаємося забезпечити щоб країна
виграла багатьма шляхами
тож дійсно у нас технічні проблеми
так на фінському боці мабуть
пан Роман доповнить пана ярко по
результатах проекту
коли
Ага Окей дякую ну взагалі-то В нас був з
ярковим сценарій і я зараз мав запитати
у нього три питання це не входило в
сценарій це цей розрив зв'язку в мене є
три питання тому я сподіваюся що я це я
ці три питання йому таки задам
Great so
dendria
Так ми повернулись до нашого сценарію
Отож Дуже дякую
за вашою емоційну промову Я хотів би
поставити вам питання
А які результати напрацювання цього
проекту є вашими улюбленими
Так дякую Дякую це дуже хороше запитання
Дякую за нього
Отож проект досягнув хороших результатів
в рамках усіх трьох озвучених мною сфер
і для мене досить складно обрати якийсь
єдиний результат єдине досягнення котре
було б
кращим чи більш потужним І знаєте дещо
відрізнялося по суті наші досягнення за
характером це дамо все ж таки
порівнювати яблука та апельсини
помаранче це можливо наскільки розумно
це робити Тобто це вже інше запитання
однак якщо
все ж таки обирати одне досягнення
товару усі команди проекту робили свій
внесок у
розвиток
а освіти у підвищення спроможності
вчителів і дійсно мені здається що
досить було потужно проведено дуже
багато тренінгів для вчителів було
покращено їхні знання та навички було
охоплено цілий
ряд нашою увагою тем і знову ж таки
питання мови і компанії популяризація
реформи І хочу сказати що от саме наші
команди дуже гарно працювали тобто
загалом дійсно мені найбільше
сподобалися досягнення сфери один де Ми
охопили настільки багато
вчителів та директорів і розбудували ось
таку потужну обізнаність
щиро дякую тоді ще одне запитання
ви зазначили що це було тривала подорож
5 років це
досить багато і
ми провели
ці
дні часом ночі обговорюючи проєкт
бачення проблеми
перешкоди з котрими зіштовхувалися на
цьому шляху що ви думаєте про
засвоєні уроки який найбільш важливий
засвоєний урок ви для себе винесли
відштовхуючись від нашого досвіду
втілення проекту Дуже дякую Романе Отож
експерти з Фінляндії та з України
співпрацювали багато років дійсно 5
років це такий тривалий період часу я
можу ще розказати що було виявлено дуже
багато слушних рішень котрі власне ще
більше об'єднали Фінляндію та Україну
але також слід визнати відмінності наших
систем освіти тобто один важливий урок
котрий так от спадає мені відразу на
думку це те що от я сподіваюся що обидві
сторони зараз мають краще розуміння щодо
сильних та слабких сторін наших освітніх
систем і це по суті ключові наріжні
камені від котрих варто відштовхуватися
коли ми будемо продовжувати наш спільний
розвиток систем освіти Ми знаємо що
система освіти
Фінляндії характе стосується
орієнтованості на потребу учнів такої
учні центричністю і вона
продемонструвала досить чи непогані
результати в рамках тих що міжнародних
досліджень Піза і освітня галузь України
також повинна намагатися досягати ось
такої постановки інтересів та потреб
учнів у центр своєї діяльності і зараз
це до речі один із наріжних каменів нуш
і один із цільових показників котрих
варто досягнути і дуже важливо також
включати саме ось такий підхід
орієнтований на учнів у всі в майбутнє
починання це те чого ми засвоїли з обох
сторін Я думаю наскільки є
важливим цей аспект і також
куліна чутливість ще один важливий
момент це дуже важливий урок Який варто
засвоїти як ми побачили
нещодавні
міжнародні конфлікти продемонстрували
наслідки
культурних чи той
ігнорування культурних відмінностей
Тобто наш досвід в Україні дійсно
дозволив нам зрозуміти наскільки важливо
наскільки важливими є навички здобуті у
сфері вивчення мови адже мова сприяє
культурній обізнаності і сприянню
визнанню цінностей тобто ось цей
культурний та мовний компонент котрий
ідуть рука в руку це те що Ми зрозуміли
більш глибину і можливо навіть речі що
хотів би додати тут це цифровізація
цифровізація все Більше та більше
прокрадається у систему освіти це
неминуча тенденція і ми сьогодні
поглянули на минуле поговорили з вами
про
майбутнє Хочу додати що ось таке
майбутнє саме за відповідними
електронними цифровізованими платформами
навчання дистанційна освіта повинна
розглядатися як можливість а не як
тільки перешкода І власне ми
розуміємо що
у нас буде все більше зростати онлайн
навчання але потрібно виносити
максимальну користь і з власне
академічного навчання у класі тобто для
дітей для молодих людей дуже важливо
розвивати своє навички спілкування
соціальні навички вербальної комунікації
тощо А цього можна досягнути тільки у
класній кімнаті тому я хотів би
зазначити що навіть незважаючи на те що
цифровізація наступає нам на 5 давайте
все ж таки розглядати її як можливість з
тим щоби підвищувати рівень взаємодії як
найкраще власне пізнавати ці платформи і
їх використовувати для більш широкої
соціалізації тобто як я зазначив
орієнтованість на учня чи учня центризм
важливість культурної чутливості та
вивчення мови котра несе у собі культуру
і також цифровізація за котрою майбутнє
освіти
тож якщо я правильно розумію то це той
пакет такий правда котрий Ми повинні
продовжувати просувати при розвитку
галузі освіти в Україні щиро дякую Чи ви
завершили вашу презентацію Чи важливо ще
дати вам можливість завершити
ні Я завершив мою частину І власне ми ще
будемо сьогодні по обіді мати можливість
поспілкуватися і знову ж таки
ми
будемо обговорювати більш детально
відповідні результати тобто Скажімо так
неможливо охопити Усе тут Та зараз Але
можливо
я хотів би попрохати вас про
декілька
таких можливостей Пізніше ще
виступити Отож чудово Я тоді з свого
боку можу продовжити і ви можете
знову ж таки долучатися Якщо вам
Оксана мене запитала
про емоції яркові на початку його його
виступили це було помітно що ярко
хвилюється
Я також Бо насправді ну 5 років це життя
Навіть якби не було ковіду і війни
А за цих обставин було дуже багато
викликів різного роду і внутрішніх і
зовнішніх Я навіть про всі Не скажу
і
Пані міністр
згадала про мою роль в цьому проекті в
мене ніколи не було такого громадського
доручення як оце
бо вона насправді відбирала багато
психічної енергії і часу і ну і
відповідно до проекту навчаємося разом я
справді я дуже добре пам'ятаю ці всі ці
2018 коли там було в нас було кілька
зустрічей з колегами Фінляндії от на той
момент
Ну в мене в бедранді був переклад
важливої книжки про фінський уроки і
тому ця тема була мені не чужа там в тій
книжці наприкінці Навіть є інтерв'ю з
автором українська мова була 26-а на яку
ця книжка була перекладена
і
на той момент ми також нас команду
міністра звинувачували в полонізації
української освіти тому Ну тому що на
польській польській колеги підтримували
нас в роботі над державним стандартам А
перед тим
впровадження підприємливої з
підприємливості української освіти
і тут нам насправді Це був дуже хороший
такий хід комунікаційний тому що проти
фінляндизації заперечувати було
складніше бо Фінляндія лідер Піза і таке
інше і зрозуміло що ну не всі ж
розуміють що насправді ніхто не не
думав про таке що можна щось взяти і
пересадити з одного ґрунту на інший але
ідеї і
конкретні рішення
у взаємодії в співпраці на рівні
горизонтальному фахівці з обох країн
вони ну безцінні
от Ну і я в якийсь момент собі поставив
Вибачте що це так виходить якось
особистісно Це моя промова Але я собі
перед собою поставив таку Ну що ти тут
взагалі робиш Ну тобі доручили щось
робити Я собі визначив свою е-е місію
щоб оце що відбувається в фінському
проекті було
інлайн з реформою нова українська школа
тому що на початку Насправді все було не
очевидно бо
проект трошечки запізнювався через там
різні технічні обставини Ну і реформа
вже почалася
а в проектній документації було написано
початкова освіта і в нас були дискусії
вже потім десь на на другому році що нам
треба додати
додати 5-6 клас і тут довелося
обґрунтовувати в такі спільні і дискусії
що 5-6 по фінській це початкова освіта і
тому Навіть якщо ми не змінимо ні
Жодного слова Жодного слова в проектному
документі то ми можемо туди претендувати
і не одразу вдалося ці зміни внести і
навіть десь там Можливо на третьому коли
ми вже фактично переходили в п'ятий клас
то можна було почути що в нас в проектів
нема ніяких вчителів-предметників от
сьогодні це пані міністр сказала про те
що тут спільнота ще не створені
і справді ми ми не в проекті ніколи не
занурювалися в специфіку кожного
предмета зокрема ми радше зупинялися на
тих ну загальних принципіах Які важливі
для вчителів незалежно від їхньої
спеціальності і як уже Ярко підкреслив
також вже керівник і створення шкільної
команди
тут було дуже цікаве лідерство з боку
аріпока це автора іншої книжки вона там
ще залишилася
і
я був вражений тоді що
він якось
багато часу присвятив от цінностям Тобто
ми якось на той момент якось схильні
були цей розділ державних стандартів так
пропускати Ну там якісь принципи є Ну і
Окей завжди принципи мусять бути на
початку документу я можу сказати знову ж
таки так про себе що я сам почав
більше більше уваги звертати саме на цей
розділ Зараз ми про це значно більше
говоримо От і для мене такий був може
от момент випробування в проекті коли
Треба було зайти в п'ятий клас пілоту І
от попри ці всі обставини що його ніби
первинно в проекті не було цього етапу
базового освіта вже і вчителів більше
стає набагато І отут проект підставив
плече по-справжньому
в зокрема от присутні тут
Юрко ідученко
коли ми
трудно домовлялися про те як має бути
побудований цей цей
навчальна програма для
по-перше
координаторів в інститутах включно з
директорами тут є принаймні одна
директорка присутня Наталя Чепурна з
Черкас
і
оця команда Інститутська директор
координатор
[музика]
якщо зрозуміти що цей годинник показує а
він показує що мені лишилося 4 хвилини
і
також координатори за усіма галузями
Тобто це велика команда в інституті 12
осіб і задум був такий що з пілотних
шкіл Оце я зараз нарешті поясню чому ми
запросили сюди пілотних шкіл бо це наша
головна цільова аудиторія в цьому
проекті і всі хто знайшли можливість
приїхати сюди особисто інший беруть
участь
дистанційно Я розумію що всі
сподіваються почутись сьогодні остаточні
відповіді як ми зайдемо в Пілот сьомого
класу я поки що про п'ятий розкажу як це
було а а далі я сподіваюся що ми
спільними зусиллями наблизимося до
відповіді Я не пообіцяю навіть сьогодні
остаточні відповіді але ми до неї
наблизимося бо тут є наші колеги з
інституту змісту освіти які розглядають
модельні навчальні програми тут є е-е
колеги з проекту із команди підтримки
реформ які працюють зараз над тим абц
сталося Ну я Міністерство очевидно те що
за цим центральним столом і
Я думаю що ми до завершення коли Андрій
Борисович повернеться до до нас він
наприкінці дня зможемо якось вже чіткіше
проговорити Саме цей етап майбутнє але я
повернуся до п'ятого класу тобто були
оці команди з пілотних шкіл І ми тоді от
почали 27
квітня з Оксаною Ярославівни з
це це був такий момент коли Уявіть собі
до того всього що це дійсно Ми дуже
тяжко прийшли до цього дня і всі
партнери були туди залучені запрошені і
ми вже домовилися як ми послідовно
будемо залучати тих партнерів з якими ми
сьогодні поспілкуємося на останній
панелі про Той досвід і про те що ми
зможемо зробити далі
От і цей момент в міністерстві гасне
світло це ще було до війни до всіх
блекаутів Там просто згасло світло Так
наглухо і ми от поки не Сіла батарейка в
телефоні в Оксани Ярославни ми
намагалися комунікувати зі свого боку
Юрій Іванович тоді був Іспанія Тамарою
теж там в залі колеги Міністерства зі
своїм телефоном в нього батарея трохи
довше тягнула і він зміг взяти слово щоб
теж розказати про Пілот от
і
я
хочу оскільки мені вже тут показують що
це що вже пора закінчувати Ні А що мало
бути говорити далі Добре
вибачте
то дивіться я думаю що тоді спільними
зусиллями от власне
проект як парасольковий і
Юрій гайдученко диригент Із залученням
фінських експертів які розповідали про
те як насправді перейти з початкової
освіти в
базову як це побудовано які можуть бути
механізми тобто все було так дуже тонко
до деталей і
десь на той час і ми зайшли в п'ятий
клас Я вважаю Ліпше ніж ніж нам тоді
здавалося це можна зробити От тобто
очевидно що що
колеги зі шкіл можуть спростувати мої
мої мої оптимістичні оцінки тому що
тому що не було посібників на столах у
дітей і ну і врешті-решт Але це вже
почалося під час повномасштабного
вторгнення Це був 22-й рік і тому
е-е це е-е
тут є в цьому певні пояснення от я
все те що ми тоді зробили підсумоване
зараз в онлайновому курсі е-е
освіторії і цей онлайн нові курс зараз
може стати частиною рішення і для і
надалі бо він стосується всієї базової
освіти
і вже в той час ми почали в нас було
кілька дуже важливих розмов з присутньою
тут пані мінних райнен і ми говорили про
те що уже зараз треба думати про
наступні етапи про зокрема про старшу
школу про профільну середню освіту
і той і тут і тут фінський досвід є
Просто дійсно унікальний і і він от
просто як навмисне зараз стає ставши
актуальніший ніж
міг бути бо оця рішення про яке мені
міністр згадала е-е в з тим що
обов'язково освіта ценз обов'язкової
загальної середньої освіти підвищений і
тому зараз все вужчим є поле для
маніпуляції що от мовляв нащо нам така
тривала освіта бо ви мовляв обов'язково
вона є далеко не всюди це правда але за
тренд Тепер уже це тренд коли вона стає
все тривалішою обов'язкова загальна
середня освіта Не кажучи вже про там
тривалість освіти на на рівні
старшої школи
і
тому
я
думаю що
колеги які презентуватимуть досягнення в
рамках кожного компоненту проекту
проекту показують як це працює Як це
може працювати далі і тому я туди в ці
деталі зараз не заходитиму я от в
п'ятницю після спілкування з командою
яка працює над
процесом
над підготовкою майбутнього проекту для
забезпечення який забезпечить
продовження цієї подорожі за дорученням
Андрія борисовича
поспілкувався зараз і отримав від них
зараз
короткий звіт який вже офіційний вони
Мені дозволили його поширювати в вузьких
колах для того щоб отримати на нього
зворотний зв'язок
і я
перевірю що ця подорож триватиме
що ми знайдемо спільно з нашими колегами
найкращій продовження
і ця Я думаю що там фокус навіть
доречніше робити власне на старшу
профільну освіту і професійного світу як
частину цього рішення в комплексі
державний стандарт профільної середньої
освіти проект його уже готовий до
громадського обговорення але це
громадська оборона розпочнеться після
того як буде спільне бачення досягнути
спільне бачення щодо можливих моделей
його впровадження
і поза тим всім ми розуміємо що основний
виклик сьогодні це зайти в Пілот сьомого
класу робоча ідея полягає в тому щоб
не обмежуватися в своїх оцих е-е
думках лише пілотом тобто оскільки Пілот
занадто занадто має коротку перспективу
і
його є дуже великі обмеження щодо того
аби його результати використовувати вже
під час першого масового туру масового
впровадження ми от розуміємо що тут
важливо
подбати про
те аби
отримувати зворотний зв'язок з масової
практики щойно Вона починається щоб не
потрапити в таку пастку в якому ми зараз
потрапили коли початкова освіта вже
пройшла свій Повний цикл 5 років а от
такого перегляду і уроків які ми з нього
могли б е-е мати для того щоб рухатися
далі усвідомлених немає Є багато
звичайно там якихось інсайтів
інтуїтивних але тут важливо власне от в
таких в такій трифазній перспективі це
все бачити Я дякую вам за увагу і
залишається трибуни
[оплески]
Дуже дякуємо пане Роман пан ярко зараз у
нас сюрприз і у нас присутній пан
Міністр освіти і науки України пане
оксен прошу
[оплески]
Доброго дня шановні колеги Шановні друзі
надзвичайно приємно мені будь сьогодні
на цьому заході попри те що він співпав
з певною кількістю інших заходів в тому
числі і урядових я все-таки мабуть не
можна так казати але надав пріоритет
цьому заходу тому що
занадто багато зроблено разом занадто
багато доброго і важливого і занадто
багато у нас з вами попереду важливих
справ я в цьому переконаний що ми
далеко не в кінці шляху попри те що ми
зараз фіналізуємо проект навчаємось
разом ми далеко не в кінці шляху
надзвичайні виклики стоять перед нами
сьогодні війна зруйновані школи
загиблі освітяни загиблі діти Все це
повинно було нас зламати морально Мабуть
так задумувалась бо інакше не били б
цілеспрямовано по освітній
інфраструктурі інакше не били б цього
спрямовано по житлових масивах
але
метане досягнута ворог не досягнув мету
і в тому числі цю мету так зламати нас
морально і в тому числі
завдяки міцності наших освітян наших
педагогів які попри все продовжували
навчати отак знаєте по-українськи вперто
принципово ви хотіли
нас зламати ми не зламалися ви це
зробили
українська освіта проявила неймовірність
стійкість
незалежно від того була підтримка чи не
було підтримки реформа нової української
школи продовжувалася завдяки освітянам
завдяки тим адептам цієї ідеології яка
була
посіяна в такий добротний грунт як
українська ментальність і українська
цінність на структура
Я переконаний в тому що у нас з вами
дуже багато роботи попереду І що всією
роботою ми з вами справимося
попри те що ми зараз змушені
концентруватися на
ключових викликах таких як безпека наших
дітей наших освітян таких як відбудова
наших закладів таких як забезпечення
елементарними і необхідними речами
складовими такими як сховища
для того щоб повернутися
в аудитор до аудиторного навчання для
того щоб припинити оце сповзання оцей
такий великий як ми вимірюємо його
сьогодні
обсяг освітніх втрат
попри те що ми шукаємо
кошти і державні і партнерські на друк
підручників на гаджети на самі необхідні
речі і вони нам дійсно потрібні Попри
все це ми все одно рухаємося шляхом
освітніх трансформацій ми все одно маємо
сміливість братися за продовження таких
важливих для освіта реформ як реформа
нової української школи ми все одно
пріоритезуємо цей вектор і йдемо цим
шляхом ми знаходимо на нього ресурси і
ми надзвичайно Дякуємо тим партнерам
завдяки яким ми вистояли ці важкі роки і
рік і роки пандемії і роки саме головне
роки війни
я дякую фінському уряду за підтримку
за цей проект в якому ми працювали разом
я дякую
всім долученим експертом які
незалежно від того були на це ресурси чи
не було на це ресурсів продовжували
працювати і просувати трансформації
конструктивні і позитивні трансформації
в освіті і ми сьогодні стоїмо перед
новим викликом Ми сьогодні беремось і це
доручення президенту України за
трансформації фактично в усій галузях в
дошкільній освіті переходимо від
парадигми піклування до
парадигма розвитку дитини ми сьогодні
беремося за продовження реформи нової
української школи за перехід її на нові
рівні і відповідно працюємо над тим щоб
зараз надолужить все втрачене в реформі
базової школи в новій українській школі
для базової школи і інтенсивно працюємо
вже над стандартами і над забезпеченням
профільної старшої школи і працюємо в
цьому контексті формуванні профільної
школи над реформою професійної освіти
професійно-технічної освіти фахової
передвищує освіти Ми сьогодні працюємо
над
трансформаціями
освіти вищої а також трансформаціями для
науки ми сьогодні саме головне дуже
конкретно працюємо над змінами в оплаті
праці в принципах і підходах до оплати
праці педагогів до освітнього
менеджменту до
цифровізації освіту до бюрократизації
відповідно нашої освіти до зменшення
всіх непродуктивних навантажень на
вчителя і освітнього менеджера власне ви
бачите спектр на який є сміливість
сьогодні українців ми не лише маємо
сміливість протистоять другій армії в
світі ми маємо сміливість і відчуваємо
гостру необхідність в для того щоб
трансформувати і розвивати нашу освіту
тому що освіта є авангардом суспільства
і це не просто слова це позиція яка
сьогодні озвучується найвищим
керівництвом країни і зокрема
президентом України в наших діалогах це
звучить наступним чином до закінчення
війни першої пріоритет оборона другий
пріоритет освіта після закінчення війни
і після перемоги першим пріоритетом для
нас стає освіта і це не лише
трансформація змісту управлінських
підходів це і трансформація просторів
велика масована будівництво і
реконструкція шкіл закладів дошкільної
освіти закладів позашкільної освіти і
заходів професійної освіти Ось що нас
чекає і кілька тижнів тому у нас була
зустріч з маргаритосом східносом це
віце-президент єврокомісії який в
черговий раз привіз для нас певну
допомогу зокрема
ще півмільйона друку підручників було
підписано нашим в наших домовленостях
але і запевнив нас в тому що Україна
буде відбудована навівши приклад що
Європа була в руїнах після Другої
світової війни і лише силами одних
Сполучених Штатів Америки вона була
відновлена До речі вітаю вас з Днем
Незалежності Америки сьогодні була
відновлена Європа а Україну яка набагато
менша ніж площа всієї Європи
буде відновлювати і Європейський союз і
Сполучені Штати Америки і
країни-партнери які не входять до
Європейського Союзу і ми сьогодні власне
Сьогодні я мав зранку розмову з послом
України в Фінляндії у них помінявся уряд
у них новий Міністр освіти Фінляндії І
в деклараціях які уже звучать зараз на
рівні програм фінського уряду Україна
звучала 27 разів
і ключове
ключова галузь співпраці - це освіта
тому ми дуже сподіваємося на продовження
і розвиток взаємодії з фінляндією і нас
надихає її приклад тому що Фінляндія
після війни і після такої важкої для
себе але дуже відважної боротьби
поставила ставку на розвиток освіти і
науки і Фінляндія сьогодні є провідною
країною в цьому і це приклад який
надихає мене особисто тому я ще раз
дякую всім нашим партнерам Я дуже дякую
нашим вчителям і я дякую фінському уряду
за цю підтримку тому що ця реформа
значною мірою реалізовувалась завдяки
вам шановні колеги тому
і ще раз моя подяка мій поклон і в першу
чергу тим людям які просувають все це і
присутні тут В цьому залі дякую вам і
успіху нам всім Слава Україні
Дякуємо пане акцент Дякуємо за дуже
надихаючі слова А зараз я хочу запросити
до сцени пана Юрія завалевського першого
заступника директора інституту
модернізації змісту освіти який
виступить із презентації вплив проекту
навчаємось разом на впровадження реформи
нуш
він шановні пані міністр
шановні учасники
господарі Дякую вам що запросили на цю
зустріч тому що сьогодні бути серед вас
говорити про ті проблеми і виклики які
сьогодні у нас є дуже сьогодні
відповідально
уже сьогодні дуже багато говорили про
роль
нашого проекту
нова українська школа і допомога
фінського проекту навчаємося разом дуже
приємно те що сьогодні дуже вже про це
багато говорили скільки фінський проект
мав допомогу новій українській школі я
повторюватися не буду Але разом з тим
пан Роман сказав що
велика заслуга у початку самого проекту
це
експеримент давайте
приємно Ту що тут зібралися в нас
директори шкіл вчителі директори
інститутів які починали цей проект і
повернемося до 17-й рік
повернемося в 17-й рік коли
вся
спільнота всі наші вчителі чогось чекали
чекали що то нового тому що ми всі
працюючи в нашій українській школі
бачили що учні уже неті школа уже не та
батьки уже не ті всі Що то хочуть хочуть
більшого хочуть реформ хочуть змін
хочуть щоб наші діти уже йшли і
навчалися по європейські і
якраз у 17-му році були проведені великі
дослідження міністр права освіти Ліля
Гриневич і тоді дуже
багато роботи ми задіяли на те щоб
розпочати нову українську школу 17-й рік
відсутній державний стандарт не було
типових навчальних програм не було
підготовлені вчителі але потрібно було
дати старт тому що у 18-му році школи
мали перейти на
уже нові рубежі і на нову парадигну
освіту перейти 18-му році не провести
експериментальне дослідження були
неможливо і тоді під керівництвом було
зроблено неможливо спомні 17-й рік коли
команди Міністерства працювали з
областями працювали з губернаторами
працювали із головами отг з батьками для
того щоб відібрати сотні шкіл відібрати
200 вчителів але це мало було на той час
достатньо було підготувати навчальні
заклади це треба було не тільки
покрасити стіни і завести меблі це треба
було завдання було
провести відповідну роботу провести
відповідну
інформаційну політику для того щоб
батьки нам повірили для того щоб вчителі
нам повірили і 1 вересня 17-го року
200 класів з підготовленими вчителями з
навчально-методичними Посібниками пішли
у перший клас І дійсно ми це зробили
працювали всі і батьки і громадськість і
керівництво
місць сіл і так далі розпочався
навчальний процес Я думаю що тут
присутні в залі ті які розпочали 17-му
році ми його виконали дали підґрунтя
коли у 18-му році було прийнято закон
про освіту був прийнятий державний
стандарт буде розроблені дві типові
програми під
авторський колектив під керівництвом
пане Романа пане пані Савченко
надруковані підручники підготовлені
вчителі і 18-му році стартувала нова
українська школа значить
експериментальні класи дали поштовх і
підготували підґрунтя для того щоб нова
українська школа почала працювати
Я думаю що сьогодні тут уже розповідали
про те яку допомогу нам давав фінський
проект ми тісно спрацювали інституція
наша спільно працювали з
експертами тому що у нашому приміщенні
якраз не дали
приміщення для експертів із Фінляндії і
тому-то кожен день
Праця починалася і зранку і під кінець
робочого дня ми завжди працювали
із самими експертами і я думаю ті
завдання які ми
працювали кожен день
і ті напрацювання які були зроблені дали
дали підні результати
хочеться сказати те що в період роботи
самого експерименту не закінчувався
самий експеримент тільки
навчально-виховним процесом головне
завдання було підготовка кадрів
підготовка кадрів і ось саме коли була
підготовка кадрів велике завдання йшло
на експериментальну роботу по підготовці
кадрів хто пам'ятає і особливо дяка
лілії Михайлівні ми почали працювати над
тим щоб педагогічні
коледжі почали працювати над тим щоб
підготовити перших вчителів які могли
працювати у 18-му році і тоді нас
підтримала Одещина моя рідна Одещина
підтримала тоді губернатор Степанова був
заступник губернатора колібурчин зараз
він заступник голови комітету Верховної
Ради де мир провели експеримент у трьох
педагогічних коледжах
і
цих трьох педагогічних коледжах було
створено все для того
у трьох педагогічних коледжах було
зроблено все для того щоб розпочати
підготовку вчителів дуже приємно те що
всі ці колективи у всіх цих колективі
коледжів підтримали нашу ініціативу і
уже до 18-го року
Одещина дала робочі місця всім вчителям
це більше 200 вчителів випускників
коледжів які почали працювати уже по
новій українській школі
Шановні колеги для того щоб
розпочати І дальше працювати по самому
експерименту важливо було не тільки
забезпечити навчальні заклади
навчально-методичній літературі яка була
яка була зроблена Але разом з тим
головне завдання було зробити освітній
простір і підготовка самих вчителів по
підготовці освітнього простору
Як ви пам'ятаєте велика робота
проводилася урядом нашої держави велика
кількість грошей десь більше трьох
мільярдів було виділено для того щоб
навчальні заклади
було було закуплено
не тільки меблі а Разом з тим і
комп'ютери
і навчально-методичні матеріали і разом
з тим
Ось на даному
саду ми бачимо це все
і разом з цим під кінець
експерименту уже у четвертому класі
вся навчально-методична література була
забезпечена повністю
підручниками забезпечені були всі
класи починаючи з першого по четвертий
клас
підручники для закладів змов
національних меншин спецко Разом з тим
велике значення було те що ви знаєте не
було навчальному методичної літератури
особливо хрестоматії і тоді
пішли на те щоб надрукувати іменно для
учнів хрестоматії із нашими українськими
авторами і поетами і ви знаєте що ці
хрестоматії були надруковані великим
тиражем для кожної дитини у нашій
навчальні заклади
закінчилася
закінчилися навчання у початковій школі
потрібно було підвести підсумки і для
цього все було зроблено для того щоб
підвести підсумки провести моніторинне
дослідження виявити і позитивні і
негативні сторони які були під час
проведення нової української школи всі
ці дослідження зараз є опрацьовується я
думаю що найближчим часом ми будемо
працювати над тим щоб вдасться зміни і
до державного стандарту і до типових
навчальних програм робочі групи зараз
працюють і я думаю що ближчим часом ці
нормативні документи будуть прийняті
Шановні колеги
закінчивши
четвертий клас уже Ми говорили ще що
потрібно було
підготувати відповідні матеріали
розробити для того щоб пілотники які
працювали у початковій школі перейшли
працювати і почали працювати уже в 5
класі ризиків було дуже і дуже багато
тому що
експериментальні класи розпочали роботу
навчальні матеріали були підготовлені
Вчителі були навчені але в цей період
виклики пандемії у 22-му році
розпочалася війна і
питань для того щоб розпочати навчання
навчально-виховний процес було дуже і
дуже багато
разом з тим команди які працювали і
скінського проекту команди які працювали
з інших інші партнери значить вони
виконали це все і
п'ятий і шостий класи експериментальні
класи сьогодні працюють і я думаю що ті
матеріали які напрацьовані сьогодні і в
5-6 класах ляжуть в основу тому що ми
сьомий клас розпочали сьогодні як ми
говорили
експериментальні дослідження уже
і новими викликами і з новими вимогами і
разом з тим з тими партнерами які нам
сьогодні допоможуть починаючи п'ятий
клас ви прекрасно знаєте що
навчальний рік розпочався без
підручників але в основному те що була
велика проведена робота із видавництвами
з авторськими колективами всі
підручники які пройшли відповідні
конкурси 5 класу а сьогодні і шостого
класу будуть розміщуватися на
відповідних платформах репозитаріях
сайтах Міністерства інституту
видавництв для того щоб діти могли ці
підручники на навчальні матеріали всіх
підручників скачати і використовувати у
навчально-виховному процесі велике
значення сьогодні для підготовки самого
проекту і продовження в сьомому класі це
підготовка кадрів і я думаю що сьогодні
велика заслуга і директорів шкіл але
основна велика заслуга сьогодні обласних
інститутів післядипломної освіти тому що
спонсори нас допомагають спонсори
організовують спонсори нам дають
допомогу але основна така важка праця
сьогодні лежить на
обласних інститутах післядипломної
освіти яким сьогодні потрібно
підготувати вчителів не так як для
початкової школи кілька двох вчителів а
сьогодні Треба підготувати вчителів по
різних предметах по різних напрямах але
А те що сьогодні робота ведеться ви
знаєте що тут у після обіду будуть
проведені уже в нас консультації
інформаційні матеріали вам будуть
роздані разом з тим про те що для
сьомого класу розроблені модельні
навчальні програми Ці моделі навчальні
програми сьогодні вони знаходяться
частина адміністрації для отримання
грифу частині надопрацювання через
кілька тижнів ці модельні програми
будуть розміщені на сайтах інституту і
Міністерства для того щоб
авторський колективи для того щоб
інститути могли з ними офіційними
програмами працювати і для того щоб ті
авторські колективи які уже попередньо
ведеться розмова із видавництвом і з
авторськими колективами щоб до серпня
місяця матеріали були підготовлені в
серпні місяці Ми продовжимо підготовку
вчителів які будуть працювати по новій
українській школі у сьомому класі разом
з тим що 1 вересня е-е
семикласники отримали матеріали а
вчителі отримали ту допомогу яка
сьогодні буде потрібна хочу вам сказати
що коли ми починали експеримент 17-му
році було з точків сьогодні продовжити
експеримент у сьомому класі 150 шків як
ми бачимо що ті вчителі ті директорі
шкіл які колись повірили нам не тільки
зберегли не тільки підтримали не тільки
продовжили свою відповідну роботу але
Разом з тим багато областей примножили
свої напрацювання і на половину більше
шкіл сьогодні працюють поексперименту і
сьогодні вважають бажаю по ньому
працювати так що Шановні колеги хочеться
ще раз подякувати вам подякувати вашим
вчителям за те що підтримали подякувати
всім нашим партнерам які допомагають в
тому числі фінський проект про який ми
сьогодні дуже багато говорять І будемо
сьогодні говорити які внесли велику
допомогу у підготовку наших вчителів і
тренерів хочеться сьогодні зробити все
щоб наші діти
сьогодні дійсно відчували те що сьогодні
вони потрібні державі і потрібні нам
дякую
Дякую пане Юрій і зараз Я запрошую пана
Василя Терещенко і проектна менеджера із
розробки навчальних програм команда
підтримки реформ ремонт і з презентацією
аналізу ефективності реформи та
дослідження про освітні втрати
радий Доброго дня шановні
колеги-колежанки радий сьогодні
представити
деякі матеріали що стосуються
діяльності зокрема пов'язані частково із
фінським проєктом навчаємося разом
з
секунду Зараз ми
одна є фраза доволі відома інколи і
авторство приписують нашому великому
другові Андрія сушляйхеру про те що без
даних ти просто ще одна людина зі своєю
думкою насправді ці слова належать
едварду демінгу так От коли ми говоримо
про успішність - це реформи і про
успішність цих 5 років які
збігли доволі швидко від початку реформи
ми говоримо передусім про те що нам
необхідні дані які підтверджували що це
реформа відбулася відбувається і
протікає з певним рівнем успішності або
неуспішності і тому далі я не зможу за
браком часу говорити про конкретні дані
але я наголошу на основних роботах які
були проведені у цьому сенсі упродовж
цих 5 років наголосити на
досягненнях і безперечно одна сумна
новина буде і цей лейтмотив песимізму в
мене буде присутній під час моєї
доповіді тому що не все вдалося не все
було зроблено але щось точно робилося
що повинно було бути зроблене про це
кожен із вас як люди які причетні до
впровадження нової української школи І
стоять на перших рубежах бо ви пілотуєте
всі ці матеріали все це було викладено
ще в 16-му році у концепції нової
української школи і там є
графік фактично імплементації цих
процесів і якби ми сьогодні переглянули
цей графік ми побачили і проаналізували
те що відбувалося в 17-18 році то ми вже
побачили що навіть на початок на 18-й
рік уже певно затримка була різні
причини цього були далі ці затримки
значної мірою ще посилилися і тут уже
згадувалися ті обставини об'єктивні і
ковід який не очікувано зрозуміло що а
потім повномасштабне вторгнення Росії і
все це позначилося на тому що
реалізувати всього просто не можна було
були суб'єктивні причини були об'єктивні
причини але в кожнім разі
За весь цей період 5-річний було
зроблено дещо зокрема вас як пілотників
мабуть
інколи ті що вас про вас піклуються що
до вас звертається з опитувальниками
хоча інколи здавалося що цими
опитувальниками анкетами різноманітними
вас просто вже до живих печінок Як то
кажуть допекли але це був один з
важливих моментів фактично забезпечення
пілотування і на рівні початкової школи
і на рівні адаптаційного циклу
базової освіти Ну як бачите із 17-го
року починаючи і до Сьогодні ці
опитування тривають і вони будуть
тривати від цього не уникнеш цього ми не
уникнемо і саме ці так би мовити гаряче
опитування які от скажімо команда
підтримки РЕ проводить
майже Кожного семестру в кінці року
інститут освітні аналітики проводить так
само доволі часто державна служба якості
освіти
долучена до цього тощо тобто різні
інституції заходять до вас щоб спитати
Як триває реформа що потрібно і в
багатьох випадках ви як ті хто давали
фактично фідбек на ці питання
ви криком кричали що не вистачає
підручників скажімо що не забезпечено
навчально-методичне забезпечення
нормальне забезпечення
навчально-методичним тощо і інколи не
вдавалося вчасно реагувати на ці питання
і
причина об'єктивна дійсно з елементами
суб'єктивізму Звісно що тому що процес
живий
авторський колективи працюють Але не всі
авторські колективи мають спроможність
підтримку щоб підтримувати цей процес
так настільки потужно щоб встигати до
початку навчального року підготувати
матеріали десь нормативні документи
невчасно готуються через те що і зокрема
останнім часом ті болючі питання про на
яких ви наголошуєте у своїх відповідях і
в усіх опитувальниках це і оплата праці
це і поділ на класів на групи це і
забезпечення підручниками і години тощо
тощо не на всі ці питання можна дати
відповідь але головне що завдяки от
моніторинговим дослідженням що
стосується процесу імплементації нової
української школи це ж Міністерство і
дотичні структури які власне опікуються
безпосередньо пілотом і потім
впровадженням
позитивних новацій в загальну практику
мають інформацію і врешті в межах
можливостей реагують на відповідні і
тому приємна новина опитування будуть
продовжуватися і на наступному цих
літелотування
приємна новина так само що ваші відгуки
про проблеми вони не зникають про них
відомо і робота над цим ведеться і
зокрема сьогодні вже звучало що і про
оплату праці і так само про інші питання
розмови розмови і конкретні дії врешті
здійснюється
крім тих питань поточних так би мовити
імплемента пов'язаних із імплементацією
реформи нова українська школа було
проведено І
найважливіші як на мене дослідження і
вони пов'язані з визначенням якості
освіти ну власне що таке Навіщо була
запроваджена реформа для того щоб
підвищити якість
навчання нашого учнівства щоб це
учнівство було готовим до життя І власне
із початку
[музика]
щойно щойно була створена концепція
відразу почали почали вести мову про те
що необхідно відстежувати те наскільки
ця реформа якісно позначає точніше
позначається позитивно на якості
досягнень учнівства і було започатковано
кілька досліджень зокрема далі швиденько
по кожному пройдуся А ви просто Майте на
увазі що матеріали цих досліджень
доступні в загальному доступі є можна
ознайомитися І що висновки за кожним із
цих досліджень
важливі як для пілотної пілотної шкіри
так і для загальної практики бо там
чимало можна знайти того що допоможе
поліпшити процес навіть в тих складних
умовах яких ми нині перебуваємо одне із
цих досліджень було проведене в пілотних
класах на початковому рівні освіти це
був початок третіх класів і планувалося
що це дослідження як і будь-яке
дослідження воно потребує верифікації
даних і так далі що його б треба було
провести повторно за цією ж моделлю На
жаль другий цикл цього дослідження не в
це реалізувати і тому маємо тільки
первинні дані стосовно того що як
відбувалися зміни в початковій школі на
етапі першого адаптаційного циклу
початкової школи Фактично це дані
охоплюють учнів які завершили другий
клас
чи варто проводити це дослідження за
аналогічною моделлю моделлю пізніше
питання риторичне але зважаючи на те що
зараз ми говоримо про перегляд реформи
взагалі від початкової ланки і до
профільної освіти то можливо не
аналогічна але подібне дослідження може
мати сенс для визначення того що
змінилося що не змінилося на рівні
початкової освіти
пізніше було проведено ще одне
дослідження воно не було глобальним
однак здійснене інститутом модернізації
змісту освіти та інститутом педагогіки
Національної академії пед наук на
репрезентативні вибірці
ви можете ознайомитися із загальними
висновками цього дослідження воно
специфічні висновки специфічні з ними
варто ознайомитися тим школам які брали
участь в спілкуванні тому що певні
проблеми - це дослідження виявило тут
можна Звісно що говорити про методологію
дослідження про підходи і так далі але
щонайменше
ті висновки ті спостереження які ми
отримали за результатами цього
дослідження також мають бути осмислені
для поліпшення процесів бо один з цих
висновків що діти пілотних класах здатні
наприклад більш є більше емоційними є
більш відкритими є більш творчими і так
далі але у дітей в пілотних класах
виявилося що скажімо досягнення з
математики гірші ніж з у дітей зі
звичайних шкіл і тут Є над чим подумати
бо врешті реформами задумували як таку
що поліпшить не тільки
соціально-емоційний ну компоненту
розвитку особистості але
компетентність ну компоненту
іншим дослідженням яке так само
відбувалося на кінець четвертих класів і
це дослідження на сьогодні варто
розглядати як
потужне явище яке з'явилося у сфері
моніторингу Це звісно що
загальнодержавний зовнішній моніторинг
якості початкової освіти його цінність в
сучасному контексті Ну просто не можна
переоцінити чому Бо цим дослідженням
вдалося охопити вибірку
репрезентативну вибірку початкових
класів до
впровадження нової української школи до
ковіду і до війни фактично в 18-му році
щойно реформа почалася встиг Український
центр оцінювання якості освіти з тих
охопити оту от Здійснити той зріз який
буде benchmarком для визначення всіх
інших динамічних процесів позитивних чи
негативних далі в 21-му році український
центр провів дослідження
так само повторно що ми маємо на 21 рік
а 21-й рік це уже по ковідний рік
результати учнівства початкової школи
погіршилися і В читанні і у математиці і
тут Ми готуємося до наступного циклу
який буде проведений на 24-го року і на
жаль сподіватися на покращення
результатів не доводиться
і правильна теза була озвучена
одним з попередніх спікерів про те що В
нинішніх умовах Лілія Михайлівна врешті
що В нинішніх умовах відсіяти те що дає
дала нова українська школа А що забрав
ковід фактично дуже важко здійснити
однак цінність цього дослідження про яке
говорю врешті полягає в тому що у нас є
зрізи ці зрізи можна глибинно
аналізувати 24-й рік 27-й рік буде і
щонайменше за належних підходів
статистичних психометричних та
аналітичних можна буде з простежити і
отой позитивний елемент в даних який
забезпечений новою українською школою
вас незміною філософії до навчання в
початковій школі і у той елемент який
з'їдалися з'їв ковід спочатку а потім
з'їдає до нині
повномасштабна війна Росії проти України
І власне на рівні початкової школи ми
маємо важливий позитив тому що
паралельно з розвиткум нової української
школи фактично її існування Може на
рівні початкової школи у нас є певна
певні елементи моніторингового системи
моніторингу і це надзвичайно важливо
якщо ми перейдемо на рівень базової
школи де зараз триває пілотування і де
зараз ми приходимо на другий цикл
базової освіти для пілотування то тут
теж слава Богу що був 18-й рік коли
Україна
встигла доєднатися до Міжнародного
дослідження якості освіти Піза У нас
знову ж таки є зріз У нас є вже й другий
зріз який було здійснено в 21-му
22-му Перепрошую році Основний етап і в
грудні ми вже отримаємо дані цього етапу
зараз триває підготовка
цього цих даних
не маючи точніше знаючи частково про ці
дані можемо відразу прогнозувати що
успішність наших 15-річних підлітків
погіршилася і для цього є об'єктивні
причини і тут ми можемо говорити що нова
українська школа фактично в 22-му році
ще не перебуває на рівні 15 категорій
15-річних учнів Тобто ми матимемо дані у
цьому випадку
пов'язані з погіршенням успішності
15-річних підлітків порівняно з 18-м
роком і ці це погіршення пов'язане з
тими умовами в яких навчалася наше
підліткова когорта підліт-підлітків в
останні чотири роки фактично спочатку
пандемії і коли ми проведемо дослідження
в 25-му році а тут приємна новина що
Україна
знайшла можливість приєднатися до
наступного циклу Піза і завдяки
підтримці міжнародних партнерів і в тому
числі такий проактивній позиції
андреасаншляйхера якого я тут згадав
візьме участь в циклі 25-го року то ми
там побачимо дані також Які ще частково
Лише будуть пов'язані з новою
українською школою але уже дані
наступного циклу 28-го року ото будуть
наші дані довго чекати але
завдяки зокрема підтримці фінського
проєкту як який як ми вже чули
продовжуватиметься в іншій скажімо в
формі але спрямований буде на посилення
саме спроможності вчителів базової школи
сподіватимемося щодо 208-го року
вдасться нову українську школу
реалізувати з позитивними ефектом з І що
забезпечить подолання
негативних наслідків спричинених
пандемією та війною
і Якщо говорити про те що зараз свіже і
частково до багатьох із вас як
представників пілотних шкіл було
дотичних це дослідження моніторингове
дослідження яке було започатковано
державної служби якості освіти державна
служба якості освіти реалізувала цей
проєкт цього року навесні в травні на
непілотних школах в свою чергу команда
підтримки реформ звернулася до вас і тут
всім хто всім школам всім вам хто
долучився до цього проєкту зреагував і
доклав усіх зусиль щоб ми так само
встигли провести цей зріз величезна
подяка маємо на сьогодні дані вони зараз
опрацьовуються
жодного слайда з цими даними не покажу
тому що все це так би мовити готується
як
важлива інформація на серпневій
конференції Тоді вийде державна служба
якості освіти зі своїми даними і тоді ми
як команда підтримки реформ вийдемо зі
своїми даними до вас як пілотників щоб
показати що
є проблемним за підсумками навчання на
адаптаційному циклі освіти і що можна
зробити для того щоб долати освітні
втрати бо власне моніторинневе
дослідження про яке зараз говорю воно
задумалося як трирічне дослідження і
фактично ці три роки зрізів дадуть
можливість побачити так само можливі
якісь
Дельту різницю між показниками цього
року наступного року і третього року і
Можливо ці показники допоможуть побачити
де дійсно є провали А де є врешті
позитивна динаміка наскільки це
освітніми втратами можна вважати питання
скажімо і методологічне і філософський і
так далі але ми повинні бути свідомі що
ми нову українську школу творимо в
умовах
надзвичайно складних і в цьому випадку
Підтримка яку надають зокрема колеги
фінський колеги в межах фінського
проєкту на рівні попередньому і зараз
надалі триватиме Це надзвичайно допомога
чому Бо фактично міняється філософія
підходів учительства до навчання от якщо
згадати ваші анкети ваші відповіді на
анкети про які я згадував на початках то
одне з питань про яке постійно говорить
вчительство ваших закладів це питання
формувального оцінювання і вже видно що
в цьому аспекті міняється підхід
вчительства Уже немає оцінки як
карального інструменту а є є формувальна
оцінка словесна вербальна як елемент
заохочення учня до розвитку своєї
індивідуальної траєкторією і коли ми
питаємо У вчителів пілотних шкіл що
потрібно ви знаєте попри те що вони
говорять стосовно чого проходили
підвищення кваліфікації і про те і про
те і про те і формувальне оцінювання там
уже є і інститути післядипломної освіти
це дають і
російський проєкт це давав але коли
питаєш що потрібно формувальне
оцінювання і тому коли
фінський проєкт буде продовжуватися то
ці питання важливо охопити це те зерно
яке проростатиме не сьогодні і не завтра
не можна бути сьогодні вчителем старої ж
інформації і завтра природитися і стати
вчителем нової інформації і тому
незалежно від того який ми дані
отримуватимемо за підсумками зрізів а
вони поки що не веселі важливо що школа
міняється із середини бо основним
гравцем на цьому полі є вчитель а міняти
вчителя особливо хто має давню практику
доволі важко і
врешті коли ми все це узагальнюватимемо
то тут важливо розуміти мінятиметься
вчительство мінятиметься якість освіти
Але для того щоб ми точно були не людьми
із власними суб'єктивними думками
стосовно будь-якій якості і зокрема
якості нової реформ реформи нової
української школи для цього необхідно
імплементувати все-таки системні зрізи
системні дослідження моніторингові
зокрема і тому от стратегія розвитку
освітніх оцінювань до 30-го року Вона
18-му році з'явилася в 19-му році
рішення
колегії Міністерства її так би мовити
затвердило але на сьогодні з цієї
стратегії реалізовано лише незначну
частину А це проблема бо нова реформа
реформа нової української школи потребує
і реформування підходів до оцінювання
всіх процесів а це означає що основні
положення цієї стратегії мають бути
імплементовані це дасть нам відповіді
набагато питань і зокрема про
ефективність цієї реформи тому якщо
договорити про те що маємо в перспективі
в найближчій робити то звісно Тобто це
переглянути графік тому що багато чогось
17-го року 16-го року коли нова
українська школа була започаткована
відтермінувалася з різних причин для
того щоб цей Після перегляду цього
графіка безперечно потребує
переосмислення концепції освітніх
оцінювань які допоможуть нам мати чіткі
Об'єктивні валідні дані за підсумками
реформи а для того щоб система
оцінювання трансформувалася в у
визначеному напрямку який уже врешті в
цій стратегії описаний і про який зараз
обговорення тривають Важливо щоб від
продовжувалися процеси які на сьогодні
позитивні намітилися зокрема це процес
цифровізації освіти бо наступні як
бачимо nmt нинішній фвв це вже
комп'ютерні оцінювання а для того щоб
проводити комп'ютерні оцінювання і
зокрема моніторингові необхідно міняти
архітектуру цих цифровізацію здійснювати
в світі і для того щоб це здійснити
необхідно гармонізувати дані щоб школа
будь-яка мала доступ до загальної бази
результатів могла бачити себе
відстежувати і відповідно приймати
скажімо рішення пов'язані з
забезпеченням внутрішньої з внутрішнім
забезпеченням якості освіти і коли все
це буде реалізовано так би мовити
ті Три кроки Це важливі зазначені на
попередньому слайді то ми отримаємо те
що було в 16-му році запланований
зокрема у питаннях моніторингу Ми
отримаємо ДПА яке даватиме зріз за всіма
учнями тут важливий момент що все про що
я говорив попередньо про моніторингові
дослідження це вибіркові це вибірки так
репрезентативні так в чомусь краще в
чомусь гірші але це не всі учні і коли
ковід
хвилею накинувся на всі країни і на нашу
країну зокрема то виникла ситуація що в
багатьох країнах де система моніторингу
були вибудування і зокрема підсумкових
оцінювань на певних ключових рубежах Там
легко було порахувати що втрачено а наша
країна опинилася в ситуації коли ДПА
кожного року проводилося до скажімо
певного періоду але даних консолідованих
зібраних проаналізованих і відповідно
читабельних для кінцевих стиль ходерів
не було і нині вже тривають розмови не
розмова а дії здійснюється тут відразу
скажу стосовно імплементації нової
системи державної підсумкової атестації
і якщо це все буде здійснено то дані ДПА
дані моніторингове дослідження
вітчизняних і міжнародних це будуть ті
дані які нам врешті допоможуть зрозуміти
наскільки ефективно ми імплементували
нову українську школу а що вона буде
ефективною в тому впевнений тому що його
цю реформу робить вчительство яке хоче
змінюватися Дякую вам за увагу і
сподіваюся на подальшу під співпрацю і
закликаю завжди заповнювати анкети які
надходять до ваших закладів освіти
Дякуємо пане Василь дуже цікава
інформація на подумати а колеги Якщо у
вас є питання можливо до нинішнього
спікера та до попереднього спікера до
пана Юрія до пана Василя У вас є 5
хвилин чи питання
якщо немає питань то прошу до сусідньої
зали де у нас буде обідня перерва і
наших онлайн слухачів ми вас Будемо
чекати тут у другій годині
дія колекції онлайн
мічухи цю дякую
[музика]
буде стосуватися мовного компоненту
нашого проекту навчаємося разом
модерувати його буде Ірина Унгурян
місцеві координаторка проекту навчаємося
разом Ірина прошу Також у нас з
онлайн-презентацією виступить і Ігор
хворостяний він буде онлайн
він розкаже про
досягнення компоненту так і також у нас
будуть
дві учасниці дискусій Наталія куриш
виконавець виконуючий обов'язки
директора інституту післядипломної
педагогічної освіти Чи Чернівецької
області Наталія Прошу і Ельвіра Яновська
лесишин навчальниця управління
регіонального розвитку департаменту
економічного та регіонального розвитку
Закарпатської овва прошу вас Ельвіра теж
на сцену
а Ельвіра буде онлайн Вибачте а тож
Наразі у нас буде виступати Ігор Ігор Ти
нас чуєш
чудово чую колеги Дякую тож передаю тобі
слово прошу
так передусім шановні учасники учасниці
конференції шановні друзі Мені
надзвичайно приємно сьогодні долучитися
до цього заходу хай він трішечки з
відтінком оцієї підсумкової легким щемом
Але я спробую бодай коротко окреслити те
чого вдалося досягнути мовному
компонентові проєкту навчаємося разом
перш за все кілька слів
найзагальніших про те чим займався
мовний компонент який стояли перед ним
завдання з якими викликами в доброму
сенсі цього слова доводилося працювати
мовний компонент було Додано інтегровано
в діяльність проєкту навчаємося разом за
фінансування Європейського Союзу і він
мав справу передусім з угорською та
румунською національними спільнотами в
двох областях на початку свого шляху
пізніше я розповім детальніше як
розширився наш
досвід і наша сфера роботи
Ішлося передусім про права людини і про
те що вивчати українську мову як
державну мову
за методикою світовою вивчення другої
мови забігаючи наперед відразу скажу що
певно ну такими дискурсивними елементами
цього процесу для нас були саме
комплексність і системність підходу і
тут не можу не подякувати всім партнерам
і коли я говорю партнери Я маю на увазі
не лише Міністерство закордонних справ
Фінляндії не лише європейські Союз не
лише Міністерство освіти і науки
України не лише місцеві управління
освіти а й кожного І кожну вчителя учня
ученицю вчительку з якими ми працювали
саме завдяки от такій от синергії
спільній роботі Нам вдалося досягнути
тих результатів які я зараз
так само звучок Якщо говорити про
системність і комплексність підходів
мовного компонента то
наша діяльність була спрямована за
трьома вузловими векторами які
стосувалися всіх кінцевих результатів
проєкту це по суті і професійний
розвиток учителів і популяризація освіти
і
покращення вдосконалення освітнього
простору тобто по суті ми перебували ми
є таким інтегративним компонентом який
пов'язаний з усіма результатами проєкту
і якщо конкретні проговорити про ці
результати то в аспекті першого вектора
в сенсі викладання адміністрування які
мали б стати у відповіднутися зі
стандартами нової української школи Нам
вдалося здійснити
ряд заходів причому ці заходи мали такий
концентричний характер Я б сказав
починалося Все з великої літньої акаде
доповідні часи коли Нам вдалося тривало
зібрати вчителів у Львові і разом
креативити
осмислювати і переосмислювати мовну
освіту
вказаних областях але
час диктував свої виклики І звісно Ми
намагалися забезпечити системну
підтримку вчителів не лише точкову раз
на рік а системно тому ми організували
серію воркшопів постійного зворотного
зв'язку з учителями Ну а наступний
виклик виклик ковіду призвів до того що
Нам вдалося
спільно з партнерами реалізувати ідею
онлайн-курсу цей онлайн-курс на сьогодні
є в відкритому доступі в безплатному
викладання української в закладах в
класі з навчанням мовами національних
меншин а і крім цього крім цієї
комплексності яку я буду постійно
згадувати я згадаю що системність і
скажу про те що
в сенсі сталості результатів проєкту для
нас надзвичайно важливо було забезпечити
подальший розвиток навіть після
завершення проєкту ідеї розроблених е-е
які мають перспективу для подальшої
імплементації саме тому от фінальним
таким аккордом була
велика масштабна підготовка 23 тренерів
10 Закарпатської 10 Чернівецької
областей це уже готові тренери і які
спроможні готувати абсолютно широке коло
не лише вчителів які працюють з
угорськими чи румунськими національними
спільнотами а в принципі вчителів які
працюють у закладах освіти з мовами
навчання національних меншин ми маємо
таких 20 тренерів
на додаток до від
підготовлених тих вчителів з якими ми
працювали і аби забезпечити цих тренерів
всіма необхідними матеріалами для
подальшої роботи навіть після завершення
проєкту ми розробили такий посібник
абсолютно практичний покроковий з
матеріалами для тренінгів для того щоб
ці тренери були так би мовити озброєні з
усіх боків і могли далі поширювати ідеї
і здобутки напрацьовані в проєкті зараз
на слайді ви бачите титул цього
посібника
крім того ще одним вектором ще одним
напрямком нашої роботи Всі ми колеги
знаємо про і Ліля Михайлівна вже
Сьогодні згадувала про те що заклади
освіти з мовами національних
викладання мовами національних меншин
національних спільнот мають в певному
додатковому співвідношенні долучитися до
викладання українською згідно з Законом
і саме тому для нас важливо було
працювати не лише з вчителями
української мови і літератури а й з
іншими вчителями вчителями біології
математики фізики хімії цього так
званого Stem циклу дисциплін І тому ми
розробили онлайн-курс який має таку
образну назву українську українська для
фізиків і ліриків І мені приємно
зазначити що уже станом на сьогодні
понад півтори тисячі вчителів з усієї
України не лише з цільових областей
отримали сертифікати про успішне
завершення цього курсу і цей курс так
само у вільному відкритому доступі
перебуває і надалі і я вірю що цей число
зростатим
тут важливо також наголосити на тому що
курс став цікавим не лише вчителям
сказаних і ми маємо надзвичайно велику
кількість реєстрації з Одеської області
з Дніпропетровської області і з інших
областей нашої держави і тому це ще раз
переконує що такий курс має значний
Потенціал є цінним для професійного
розвитку вчительства
знову про системність Гаразд ми
працювали безпосередньо з учителями ми
підготували тренерів не лише вчителів
української мови і вчителів фізики хімії
математики біології частково але
освіта це завжди інвестиції в майбутнє і
зокрема якщо говорити про інвестицію в
майбутнє самої освіти то згадати заклади
вищої освіти ну минути їх увагою просто
неможливо тому Нам вдалося в плідній
співпраці з двома університетами з
чернівецьким національним університетом
і з мукачівським державним університетом
розробити три програми
робочі робочі робочі Програми навчальних
дисциплін з вивчення української як
державної мови і імплементувати ці
програми у згаданих університетах це
один Мукачівський університет і дві
програми в Чернівецькому національному
педагогічної факультет і філологічний
факультет тобто по суті знову ж ці
інвестиції в майбутнє зокрема
реалізовувалися за напрямком роботи з
майбутніми вчителями а не лише з
учителями які сьогодні вже безпосередньо
працюють у закладах освіти крім того
окрім згаданих ще від початку проєкту
завдань Ми зрозуміли усвідомили що
вчительство сьогодні потребує конкретних
практичних готових інструментів для того
щоб
підтримувати власне це вчительство у
діяльності
зрозуміло що виклики які поставив і
ковід і повномасштабна війна і агресія
Росії
і так скоротили малий час для вчителя і
тому конкретні практичні інструменти які
можна використовувати за принципом бери
і роби Ну набувають просто непересічної
ваги і саме з цією метою Нам вдалося
розробити посібник для вчителів дуже
практичний посібник Ми назвали його
красивими тафорично українська для всіх
ось тим не менш цей посібник містить
цінні десь третина цього посібника цінні
практичні готові інструменти які можна
використовувати буквально в роботі тут і
зараз не можу не згадати ще посібник для
університетів це такий масштабний
співпраці з фінськими експертками проєкт
з української як державна вивчення і
навчання от саме для того бізнесу в
закладах вищої освіти про який я
згадував Ну і на фінальній стадії
розроблення ось буквально скоро має бути
як гарячий пиріжок вийти з друку
посібник для вчителів мистецтво
оцінювання в нуш ми чудово розуміємо
реагуємо на запити щодо того і пан
Василь Терещенко сьогодні вже згадував
що оцінювання - це одна з таких
актуальних одне з актуальних питань яке
стоїть перед вчительством також
долучилися до розроблення модельної
навчальної програми інтегрованого курсу
для класів з навчання мови корінного
народу та або національної меншини це те
що було зроблено за першим нашим
вектором роботи навіть Як то кажуть
понад позапланова що стосується другого
вектора другого аспекта - це
комунікації це підтримка реформи нової
української школи
освітянської спільнотою широкою
громадськістю я почну з мовних таборів
бо власне з них стартував мовний
компонент проєкту навчаємося разом це
табори бомбезно і весняні літні з
підготовки як з підготовки до
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання таким
експрес-методом з застосуванням
інтерактивних методів прийомів форм
взаємодії так і такі більш
соціокультурні
варіанти вивчення мови під час літніх
таборів для учнів і учениць п'ятих тире
9-х класів коли ковід уне активи в
подальшу реалізацію цих таборів Ми
вирішили що перспективний напрацьований
досвід варто узагальнити систематизувати
і тому зараз знову ж таки у відкритому
доступі є дві частини посібника бомбезна
українська як спланувати та провести
мовний табір в якому конкретно розписано
кроки всі інструменти необхідні для
імплементації цих таборів не лише в
умовах дистанційного навчання і в умовах
онлайн
Перепрошую
навчання віч-на-віч безпосереднього
після завершення нашого проєкту Тому це
є інструмент як на мене теж є досить
потужним в межах цього ж вектора
діяльності Ми реалізували дві
комунікаційні компанії я відразу скажу
що нашою основною метою цих
комунікаційних компаній було досягнути
тих
громадян і громадян України які на жаль
не спілкуються українською які говорять
мовами національних меншин і тому
основний фокус цих комунікаційних
компаній якщо дозволити таке слово був
достукатися саме для цих людей було
підготовлено серію роликів угорської
румунською мовами які були спрямовані
саме на популяризування вивчення мови
української мови державної Я хотів би
зараз буквально використати 2 хвилини
часу і показати вам один із прикладів
таких роликів як на мене вони яскраво
демонструють такий такий мультикультурне
обличчя України і разом з тим повагу
потребу і вимогу володіння державною
мовою
[музика]
Ну і на сам кінець останній Вектор Я
буквально 20 секунд де я встигну
розповісти для нас був вчинена
найбільшим викликом Але разом з тим він
був чи не найважливішим це
вдосконалення освітнього простору
освітнього середовища в закладах з
мовами навчання над іншими Нам вдалося
видати комплекти посібників із вивчення
української як державної мови для
початкової школи четвертий клас от зараз
буквально завершується
видання і найближчим часом другий третій
четвертий класи поїдуть в заклади освіти
з мовами навчання національних меншин
також без цифрових інструментів
нікуди сьогодні тому ми підготували
багатомовний онлайн словник математичних
термінів і мобільний застосунок для
вивчення української мови в початковій
школі з фокусом саме на
заклади освіти з мовами навчання
національних меншин власне всі
детальніше з усіма цими продуктами ви
можете познайомитися
у вільному відкритому доступі А в мене
все І я передаю слово Ірині лишаючись
Тут поруч з вами
Дякую Ігорю я сподіваюся ви занурилися в
атмосферу мовного компоненту проєкту
навчаємось разом І власне Зараз ми
поспілкуємося з тими хто був тими нашими
бенефіціарами протягом роботи проєкту
поруч зі мною пані Наталя пані ельвіро
якщо можна щоб нам було видно пані
Ельвіра
поки під’єднуються пані Ельвіра хочу
сказати що нам Дуже хотілось щоб тут всі
шість крісел були заповнені але ну маємо
таку ситуацію і війна і тому не всі
змогли приїхати пані Львів вітаю І
розпочати нашу бесіду я би хотіла з того
що я зачитаю коментар який ми отримали
буквально Минулого тижня коментар з
подякою цитую за надані хороші якісні
навчальні посібники навчаємось навчаємо
української разом навчальні посібники
значно полегшать вивчення та викладання
української мови для учнів та учениць в
класах з навчання мовою національних
меншин а також допоможуть у створенні
сприятливого середовища для вивчення
державної мови що сприяє у вирішенні
проблеми соціальної етнічної мовленнєвої
роз'єднаності учнів прийміть щиру
вдячність за небайдуже ставлення до
дітей які тільки починають вивчати
українську мову це відгук від одного із
закладів освіти Закарпатської області
який вже отримали наші посібники Ну і
власне ми почали говорити про середовище
освітні і тому я звертаюсь до наших
спікерок запитанням як на вашу думку
діяльність мовного компоненту вплинула
на розвиток освітнього середовища саме
закладів
наших цільових областей тобто
Чернівецької з Закарпатської а саме на
навчання української мови в класах з
викладання окремих предметів угорської
або румунською мовою пані Наталю якщо
можна питання спочатку до вас дякую пані
Ірина Доброго дня шановні колеги коли
жанки всі хто сьогодні присутній тут
кому не байдуже сьогодення і майбутнє
нашої освіти і сьогодні маємо можливість
передати вітання від освітян Буковини
від тих хто був учасниками
проє ми навчаємось разом саме реалізував
мовний компонент ми вдячні за те що мали
можливість реалізувати державну політику
в з питань мовних статей закону України
про освіту і статей закону про загальну
середню освіту тому що це для нас
Важливо щоб кожна дитина отримала якісні
освітні послуги і саме завдяки тим
ресурсам які були розроблені в рамках
проєкту навчаємося разом Ми отримали Як
ви сьогодні почули і навчально-методичне
забезпечення для учнів початкової ланки
освіти щодо навчання української мови Це
є велика вдячність і Я сьогодні навіть
сказала Оплески нашим
партнерам які дали можливість отримати
такі ресурси це і підручник
українська для всіх Тому що це є
потужний інструмент для вивчення
української мови в закладах з навчанням
де українська мова не є рідною це і
проведення літніх таборів і посібник з
бомбезно тому що саме ті літні табори
які тривали
18-19 році вони нам дали чудові
результати і про ці результати Я
сьогодні хочу
гордитися і довести до вас до відома
серед
86 учнів випускних класів які здавали
національний мультиппредметний тест
86 Чернівецькій області здали на 200
балів ми маємо 12 учнів з закладів де
велася навчання
де українська мова не рідна мова це
старововчинецький ліцей і
красноїльський ліцей
в цих ліцеях по шість дітей здали
мультипредметний тест на 12 балів з 27
учнів які здали українську мову на 12
балів двоє дітей з закладів де
навчаються мовою національних меншин
якщо аналізувати зовнішній незалежне
оцінювання до 20-го року в нас були дуже
плачевні результати то зараз ми маємо
гарні результати І це все завдяки
мовному компоненту який реалізувався в
рамках проєкту навчаємося разом тому
вдячність і я думаю що ми маємо гарні
ресурси їх будемо використовувати вони у
нас не будуть лежати мертвим грузом
дякую пані Наталю пані ельвіро якщо
можна ви поділіться я як на вашу думку у
вашій області да спрацював мовний
компонент
Добрий день колеги коліжанки Я дуже рада
і тішуся тому що я можу бути сьогодні
серед вас бо я вже якби з 19-го року
недотична до галузі освіти але освіта
залишається Моїм хобі і
в принципі до мовних таборів бомбезно і
бомбезний Я ще дотичність мала
Скажу вам що це було Можливо тоді на
старті на початках на
цьому впровадженні проекту все не дуже
так легко але судячи з того що я
дізналася від колег і
знаю що цей мовний компонент спрацював
що проект був вдалий
знаєте Я завжди
згадую одне повідомлення яке ми зробили
яке я зберегла собі після
весняного бо наступного кемпу багато
різні 19-го року це тоді був такий
пілотний проект в області
воно було розраховано на 200 учнів 75
учнів яких складали тільки учні
берегівського району і коли проводили з
ними анкетування що для них цим було
проектом
згадую з теплотою можливо і з мурашками
до по шкірі
повідомлення дитини яка написала Уявіть
собі пустелю як Чорногора А в ній із
просвітла що то з'являється то згасає а
потім все починається знову цей проект
цей світло і я думаю що ці прекрасні
слова
такі які зачіпляють вони є свідченням
того що цей проект був вдалим
Я кажу знову повторюся Мені важко
говорити
результати
21-22 років але коли в 19-му році ми
провели два оці мовні голки і проводили
аналіз
порівняння здачі ЗНО дітей до табору і
після проведених таборів ці чотири школи
дітей які долучалися результати було
Значно краще я не можу сказати що це
зразу була так стартпідготовка така
хороша але те що психологічний був
момент і те що ми вселили завдячуючи
цьому проекту
Віру
[музика]
майбутніх студентів у себе це був
великим фактом
тому я дуже буду дякувати всім дотичним
до цього проекту і пану Ігорю
хворотянумо і оксаніної чепуренко яка
своєю громадською організацією
долучалися до проведення цих таборів
Ксенії Охотник велика заслуга
працівників Департаменту освіти і пані
Анни собкову яка вже зараз не працює і
велику зусилля до цього проекту
докладала Андріана і Юлія налока чи вона
й долучалася і до написання книг Я знаю
що
так маємо невеличкі технічні проблеми
думаю Ми продовжуємо пані Ельвіра до нас
приєднається
наступне запитання пані Наталя ми
побачили щойно цей такий перелік
продуктів які були створені за період
тривалості проєкту от Як ви думаєте яке
можливе подальше використання оцих всіх
продуктів у Чернівецькій області
Ну як я продовжу як я завершила
попередній відповідь на запитання Що ми
будемо проваджувати ми бачимо вже і
окреслили з пані Іриною з тренерами тому
що наразі в нас є підготовлено 10
тренерів з них три тренери це
працівники інституту післядипломної
педагогічної освіти і 7 тренерів це
педагоги закладів освіти області і ми
вже бачимо ті вектори руху в подальшому
перш за все чудовий посібник мистецтво
оцінювання в новій українській школі і
скільки б навчань ми не проводили
скільки б ресурсів не пропонували
вчителів завжди залишаються знаки
питання і цей посібник є ще одним таким
продуктом Який дасть відповіді на деякі
запитання і ми вже плануємо в серпні
місяці певні майстерки щодо
популяризації даних продуктів наступ
чудова програма яку ми чекали для нової
української школи інтегрований курс
українська мова і література для
закладів національних де викладається
мовою національних меншин Це новий
продукт такого ми не мали і
плануємо десь на жаль поки що ніхто не
обрав тому що лише в цьому році була
схвалена ця програма Ми плануємо також
проведення певних практикумів для того
щоб довести переваги цієї програми
довести можливості цієї програми щоб
впроваджувати її дієво в освітнє
середовище закладів освіти
Ельвіра не бачу Ну добре в нас
залишається півхвилини і я такий як на
завершення пані Наталю назвіть будь
ласка одне слово яке у вас асоціюється з
яким ви можете описати Той досвід
мовного компоненту в отримала
Чернівецька область
Якщо ж одне слово то практичність а якщо
розшифрувати Ми уже
розбудовуємо освітній хаб по-мовному
компоненту і з 1 вересня хап буде
працювати на базі хабу не буде тільки
навчання це і консультації це і
підтримка це і ресурси і навіть знаю хто
буде керувати цим хабом пані Ірина хоче
не хоче
в неї великий досвід і підготовлені
тренери уже погодилися працювати в таких
Дякую
усім і я завершу своїм одним словом для
мене ці роки були неймовірні Дякую всім
за увагу
Дякую колеги тож Наразі у нас нова
дискусійна панель яка буде присвячена
питанням створення освітнього середовища
і яку буде модерувати наш колега Юрій
гадученка експерт
третього класу навчаємось разом прошу
Дякую Шановні колеги Дякую Дмитро за
слово
Звісно що Панельна дискусія неможливо
без учасників панельної дискусії тому
під ваші Оплески Ми запросимо на цю
сцену наших панелістів
запрошую Пані Олено Дубовик заступницю
директора інституту модернізації змісту
освіти координатора а третього класу
навчаємось разом Пані Олено
запрошую також пана
Івана юрічука заступника директора
державної служби якості освіти пане
Іване вітання
Запрошуємо також пані Юлю Романенко
експертику команди підтримки реформ
Міністерства освіти і науки України
І звісно Панельна дискусія неможливо без
практики без керівників які увесь цей
час
створювали разом з величезними командами
закладів загальної середньої освіти те
про що ми будемо сьогодні говорити
навчальне середовище Запрошуємо пані
Оксану проскуру директорку Київської
гімназії східних мов
і Пані Тетяну жорницьку директору
директорку закладу загальної середньої
освіти номер 26 міста Одеси
всі вже говорили сьогодні дуже багато
про те власне з чим асоціюється реформа
нової української школи і сьогодні
лунало про те що власне Найбільше що
обговорюється зараз формувальне
оцінювання тож в нашій панельній
дискусії Ми сьогодні спробуємо
застосувати
формувальне оцінювання про яке всі ми
говоримо так а саме рефлексія є дуже
багато напрацювань проекту які пов'язані
з розвитком навчального середовища це
власне робота з директорами за час
проекту було підготовлено більше ніж 500
директорів закладів загальної середньої
освіти з більше п'яти заходів такого
всеукраїнського рівня з різними
представниками різних шкіл було
проведено курс для новопризначених
керівників на основі якого було
розроблено власне типову програму
підвищення кваліфікації і я знаю що в
нас є в залі пані Людмила яка була одні
із
учасниць цього курсу на основі власне
пілотування було визначено запити
директорів з чим директор приходить в
перший рік управління закладом загальної
середньої освіти також дуже важливо що в
процесі власне проекту разом з
міністерством освіти і науки України
інститутом модернізації змісту освіти Ми
шукали Шлях який допоможе власне і
керівнику і вчителю розробляти
самостійно навчальну програму керуючись
новими державними стандартами і ось тут
з'явилося рішення конструктор Ми теж про
нього сьогодні поговоримо
І звісно що навчальне середовище
неможливо без навчальної літератури і
протягом власне розвитку реформи нової
української школи ми з вами як
вчителі-практики точно побачили
наскільки
урізноманітнилася ця література які
формати як змінився власне формат
підручників і дидактичних матеріалів і
поговоримо також про власне які ж
виклики також є у цьому процесі Оскільки
ми розуміємо що предмети які мали одну
навчальну програму мають сьогодні
7-8 налентано і все це потребує
величезної шаленої роботи експертів саме
тому проект навчаємось разом провів
більше п'яти курсів для розробників
освітнього контенту І сьогодні ми
згадаємо про власне нове інноваційне
рішення до підготовки таких експертів це
національна платформа
яка розроблена за підтримки проекту і
інституту модернізації змісту освіти
школа експертів освітнього контенту яка
допоможе всім тим хто хоче сьогодні
критикувати стати експертом розібратися
в питаннях експертування освітніх
матеріалів і допомогти авторам власне
покращувати наше освітній контент Бо в
цій залі Ми зараз і наші панелісти
заради однієї мети власне
створення нового
плекання нового покоління українців яке
зможе зробити нашу систему освіти і нашу
Україну ще більш потужною і
результативніше в питанні розвитку саме
навчальної літератури проект працював з
розробниками понад 350 авторів авторів
пройшло навчання з фінськими і
українськими експертами а також це курси
для розробника розробників освітнього
контенту І власне вчителів бо сьогодні
дуже багато залежить від того наскільки
якісний контент обирають наші вчителі
наскільки вони можуть побачити ці нові
формати наскільки вони можуть
співставити власне навчальні матеріали з
базовим стандартом і ось тут разом у
співпраці з міністерством освіти і науки
України ми провели курс які допомогли
вчителям зрозуміти що таке якісний
контент як відрізнити власне контент
нової української школи і традиційний
контент і сподіваємося що надалі Це ці
напрацювання які До речі ми зібрали під
однією парасолькою це нуш хамп і в
сьогодні ваших буклетах є покликання на
цей ресурс який допоможе вчителям знайти
ті матеріали які були розроблені
проектів і зрозуміло що без цифрових
навичок ми знаємо сьогодні що дуже
багато шкіл працюють у На жаль вимушено
працюють в онлайновому режимі тому
навички працювати з цифровим освітнім
середовищем який сьогодні дуже важливі і
проектаж реалізував
онлайн-курс і вже понад тисячі вчителів
завершили навчання на платформі Едера
курс має назву вчителів курсі 13 модулів
які допоможуть вчителям сформувати
базові цифрові навички і створювати
якісно цифровий контент власне такий
Вибачте колеги такий короткий
бекграунд того про що будемо говорити
і перше запитання мабуть пані Оксана
перший усміхнулася буде до вас
за підтримки проекту
величезної команди експертів різних
інституцій було розроблено професійний
стандарт керівника закладу загальної
середньої освіти власне дуже багато
дискусій про те чи потрібен цей цей
документ цей стандарт чи не потрібен як
він може допомогти керівнику зокрема у
питанні розбудови освітнього середовища
Дякую Юра
крайні завжди розпочинають я зрозуміла
Насправді Я хочу сказати що я щаслива
долучитися до проєкту протягом цих років
тому що коли ти
долучаєшся сам ти і зростаєш сам в першу
чергу тому що це
нова експертність нові знання новий
досвід і можливість дійсно і власного
розвитку в першу чергу
щодо професійного стандарту я
абсолютно впевнена в тому що керівник
закладу освіти
це той лідер
який має в першу чергу вести за собою
колективи вести за собою освітян і є
така поширена думка що організація не
може працювати на рівні більшому ніж
рівень його керівника тому що якщо не
розвивається керівник в першу чергу то і
не розвивається сама організація ну це є
такі управлінські закон
Працюючи в цьому проекті
Я хочу сказати що його перевагою є те
що матеріали які
готувалися і в яких я безпосередньо
брала участь вони є безкоштовними вони є
доступними і вони є реальними
реальними тобто вони є актуальними
і
ми знаємо що
професійний стандарт керівника це є вже
і вимога часу Тобто ми маємо як
керівники виконувати цю вимогу і
підвищувати свій професійний рівень
щодо Юра зараз хочу ще сказати одну
ремарку я тебе слухала
уважно і буквально
[музика]
готувала написати таку такий пост на
своїй сторінці у Facebook що цей проєкт
дає можливість
освітянами керівникам в одному місці
знайти всі необхідні матеріали для
підвищення власного професійного
розвитку і подивилася всі ресурси які
зібрані в одному місці І
навіть захотіла запропонувати освітянам
що якщо ви ще не встигли
щось десь навчитися новим навичкам то
Заходьте будь ласка Тут є різні
матеріали і достатньо професійні і
змістовні для власного професійного
розвитку
враховуючи що у нас дуже мало часу я
хочу сказати
завершити свій виступ одні цитатою щодо
професійного розвитку не тільки
керівника закладу освіти і
будь-якого вчителя і працівника закладу
освіти
цитатою з Аліси в Країні Чудес Якщо ти
хочеш сьогодні залишатися на місці Ти
маєш бігти з усіх ніг Якщо ти хочеш
зробити Крок вперед ти маєш бігти вдвічі
більше інакше спрацює принцип ескалатора
тому Дякую за ту роботу яка проведена
Дякую за залучення і Дякую що ви
надихаєте і змінюєте освіту дякую дякую
пані Оксано і передамо мікрофон відразу
пану Івану державна служба якості освіти
постійно моніторить вже Сьогодні
згадувала велика кількість різних
опитувань так і різних досліджень і
точно має фідбек і зріст того Як
змінювалася освітнє середовище
закладах загальної середньої освіти які
відгуки були у батьків
проте Як змінювалася освітнє середовище
і власне як ми бачимо наступні кроки в
реалізації
реформи в базовій і профільній школі
Вітаю всіх колеги я кілька слів скажу
перед тим як почати відповідати на
запитання Я хотів би по-перше подякувати
нашим колегам з фінського проекту і
пасії рейні Каїн і туя лаурен і аріпок
артулах та карі
ярко лампіселька і наші колеги
з української сторони Роман Шиян Наталя
софій
Юра гайдученко і багато-багато інших які
були долучені до цього проекту я
пам'ятаю коли цей проект розпочинався і
мені імпонували те як
вони підходять до визначення пріоритетів
і як вони підходять до планування роботи
і ми уже тоді почали деякі речі брати
для себе
власне як Ну якась модель так як
будувати свою власну діяльність
Я знову ж таки перш ніж почати про
освітнє середовище Я би хотів сказати що
і скажімо у будові системи сертифікатів
вчителів чи в роботі з освітніми
програмами Ми також мали таку тісну
співпрацю з проектом попри те що я
наскільки пам'ятаю Ця робота не була в
пріоритетах від початку так від початку
коли проект запроваджувався Ця робота не
була в пріоритетах Але тим не менш по
ходу проекту проявив таку виявив таку
гнучкість і вони нас підтримали і
скажімо той проєкт який ми зараз
називаємо сертифікацією вчителів а я
вважаю що це дуже класний успішний
проект він
багато в чому саме такий завдяки
підтримці фахівців фінського проекту
тепер що стосується середовища дивіться
друзі Я би хотів сказати таку річ
як завжди там різноманітні опитування
дослідження показують що є
знаєте розподіл як правило відбувається
за якоюсь такою
кривою тобто є ті кому все абсолютно
подобається всі кажуть це просто космос
ми цього чекали все життя є такі які
кажуть це взагалі ні про що От ми знаємо
тоді було класно і це було це все
працювало
натомість більша частина кажуть Ну окей
Подивимося як воно спрацює в майбутньому
але я би хотів трошечки про інше сказати
Я би хотів сказати про те що
будь-яка
будь-яка історія пов'язана з освітнім
простором Вона може просто залишитися
карго-культом Так званим коли ми бачимо
форму Так але якщо там нема
якогось наповнення смислового то воно не
буде працювати Тому освітнє середовище
на моє переконання має бути частинкою
ширшого комплексного рішення
якоїсь композиції з матеріальних те що
стосується простору і якихосьмислових
речей які стосуються цінностей які
стосуються змісту освіти які стосуються
які стосуються там результатів навчання
тобто не матеріальних якихось речей так
якщо освітнє середовище є органічною
частиною отакого ширшого комплексного
рішення тоді воно працює
якщо цього нема то ми можемо привести в
школу що завгодно і це все буде класно І
батьки будуть казати Ой яка в нас гарна
школа але не буде того результату на
який ми очікуємо І тут якраз от
ще одна річ з якою ми працювали з
фінським проектом нас консультував арі
пока неодноразово це питання які
пов'язані з освітніми програмами шкіл
от Мені здається що освітня програма
школи це та точка
прикладання зусиль так в якій шкільна
команда разом з шкільним лідером з
директором школи
з іншими стихолдерами можуть оцю
композицію побудувати композицію його з
освітнього середовища і тих
нематеріальних смислових речей і якщо їм
це вдається
тоді освітнє середовище працює Якщо ж не
вдається знову ж таки повторюся туди
можна вкласти дуже багато ресурсів але
воно не буде працювати Воно не буде той
давати той результат на який ми
розраховуємо
тоді наступне питання А чи достатньо ми
робимо для того щоб
це все працювало так як ми хочемо не
знаю не впевнений Якщо говорити про
стандарт чи повернутися на хвильку до
стандарту професійного стандарту
я би тут поставив два питання
Коли і як
цей стандарт впроваджувати бо мабуть чи
треба чи не треба Ну
справа в тому що ми зараз перебуваємо в
дуже цікаво дуже цікавому етапі розвитку
системи освіти у нас відбувається зміна
отаких культурних засад Так у нас
відбувся
супередивними мислимо зараз трошечки
по-іншому принаймні мали би
тому чи треба якісь такий орієнтир для
директора
мабуть треба
як цей стандарт впроваджувати отут можна
дискутувати Але мені здається що можна
би було зробити більше і це не це зараз
я не про проект проект запустив цю
історію
проект Зробив те що мав зробити але далі
ті хто мали би підхопити політичні
гравці в країні органи влади центральні
органи місцеві органи можуть тут можна
було зробити більше за принаймні там за
останні два-три роки можна було зробити
набагато більше але
цей процес невідворотній Тобто ми зараз
маємо це робити зараз мені здається
більш сприятлива ситуація і тому це
потрібно робити
освітні програми
знову ж таки чи ми до кінця розуміємо
потенціал цього інструменту може і
розуміємо А може навіть і не до кінця
розуміємо мені здається тут якраз є отой
простір для такої дуже класної роботи
Коли по-перше ми можемо через цей
інструмент Я завжди про це кажу останнім
часом це така точка трансформації точка
фазового переходу коли колектив команда
зірок стає командою зіркою командою
шкільною командою і тоді Ця команда це
ніби одні й ті самі люди формально так
але це люди які дивляться в одну сторону
які мають поділяють одні цінності які
які розуміють як досягти спільного
результату одна команда один результат І
тут якраз Якщо говорити про середовище
оця команда має думати як зробити це
середовище органічною частинкою якоїсь
такої ширшої композиції яка дасть нам
той результат який ми який ми хочемо
досягти
Дякую згадали про освітню програму
і я думаю що ми зараз дамо слово відразу
пані Тетяні а потім повернемося до
навчальної літератури пані Тетяна
прозвучала дуже класна фраза як зробити
з команди зірку і в проекті був Ну
мабуть один із таких дуже
масштабних викликів провести курс
навчання
пілотних закладів освіти разом з
координаторами єдиною командою і
для когось це був
справжній такий позитивний виклик а
хтось не зрозумів що це був виклик і
були різні думки навчання командою за і
проти як заклад загальної середньої
освіти номер 26 міста Одеси який
навчався одночасно і потім створював
нову освітню програму для
за новим державним стандартом
щиро дякую за запитання і Передаю
вітання від усієї освітянської галості
міста Одеси Одещини своєї рідної 26-ї
школи всім
учасникам сьогоднішнього заходу І
взагалі всім хто протягом цих років
пілотував проект тому що ви справжні
герої освітнього фронту Тому що в цей
час такий важкий це зовсім не просто а
пілотувати цей проект це ще важче тому
дуже приємно бачити Дуже багато знайомих
облич де ми пересікались на вебінарах на
різних формах Дуже дякую пане Юрію за те
що він запросив Ну і дійсно щодо
освітньої програми і щодо командної
роботи гарним викликом і гарним досвідом
саме була робота в проекті навчаємося
разом і в студії освітніх управлінців
Гаррі Поттер де саме була тема командної
роботи дійсно все те чого міг директор
навчитися під час ось таких практичних
занять успішно було перенесе на формат
школи ми дійсно складаємо освітню
програму колективну ми не робимо це самі
це роблять всі скрам групи кожен
по-своєму предмету це збираються учителі
які абсолютно
мозковим штурмом дискусію обирають
програми потім ми їх пропонуємо
обов'язково батькам де батьки мають і
учні право вибору Тому в нас освітня
програма основний документ який в
кожного з вас основний документ школи і
складається він колективно тому
навчальні програми вони можуть бути
навіть різними хтось обирає інтегрований
курс літератури і української мови хтось
обирає тему світу хтось обирає
драматургію і театр і обов'язково думка
враховується тому знання які були
здобуті під час Ось цього нашого проекту
вони досить знадобилися в командній
роботі І що хочу чим завдячити самому
проекту що досить виростають самі
вчителі вони дійсно стають зірками і Це
сузір'я тому що вони проводять в нас
одна школа пілотна в Одесі яка пілотує
цей проект проводять апробуючі вебінари
не тільки на місто а вже на
всеукраїнському рівні що дає ріст що дає
натхнення що дає творче середовище
мотиваційне середовище і школа звісно
стає і демократичною і практику
орієнтованою і безпечною і розвивальною
саме те чого нас навчив цей проект Дякую
вам дякую пані Тетяно Олена Анатоліївна
в нас подвійний виклик бо вона
залишається дуже мало часу і
Один із найбільших викликів в новій
українській школі це власне навчальна
література і дидактика от Якщо порівняти
власне ту навчальну літературу яка
готувалася за попередніми державними
стандартами і далі література яка вже
пройшла
пілотування і масову практику в
початковій школі і в першому циклі
базової освіти які тенденції Можна
помітити та позитивні які виклики є у
цьому всьому процесі тому що інститут
модернізації змісту освіти займається не
тільки навчальною літературою лише і
модельними програмами та І що беремо з
собою далі для того щоб поширювати і
удосконалювати
Ну ти що навчальна література її якість
- це один з чинників є такий дуже
суттєво впливають на якість нашої освіти
я не думаю що хтось буде зі мною
сперечатися всі погоджуються всій залі
день не тільки всі наші освітяни Юрій
Якщо порівняти то навчальну літературу
яка була написана за старою українською
школою і нової української школи дійсно
це різне навчальне літератури вони
відрізняють багато різних ну Скажем так
відмінностей навіть якщо автори писали
раніше пишуть зараз вони вже пишуть
по-новому сказати Так що ми
повністю задоволені якістю нової від
навчальної літератури для нової
української школи хочеться краще але як
сьогодні казав Василь Терещенко про
вчителя якщо він вчора працював по
старому а сьогодні він має повністю
змінитися і працювати по-новому такого
не буде Ну так само і з авторськими
колективами якщо вони вчора писали
по одному стилю вони сьогодні не можуть
зразу почати писати по-новому але все ж
таки нова українська школа у нас вже
підручники шостого класу готові зміни є
і навіть в цьому році у нас був
повторний відбір першого класу
підручників і навіть вже посібників ті
що 5 років назад 18-му році відбиралися
і ті що зараз і навіть один і той самий
авторський колектив порівняти їх
підручник 5-річний давнини і новий він
вже новий тому що за цих 5 років
відбулася апробація цієї навчальної
літератури відбулися зміни і у вчителях
і в авторах все ж таки коли 18-й рік
наша автори підручників Ну не були
настільки сильно обізнані в новій
українській школі і не до кінця можливе
розуміли державний стандарт час зробив
своє досвід спрацював і вже набагато
краще але
[музика]
Ми думаємо що зупинятися неможливо Не
потрібно і ми хочемо ще більше
удосконалення тому завдяки фінському
проекту
напевно я анонсую вперше Так зараз на
велику аудиторії тому що воно ще не
оприлюднена ніде був розроблений дуже
знаєш і точки зору необхідний проект ми
вирішили подивитися на якість навчальної
літератури трошки з іншого боку да були
переведені величезна кількість в
семінарі вебінарів навчань для авторів
для редакторів Це абсолютно необхідна і
правильно Ми дуже вдячні фінському
проекту але ми вирішили піти з іншого
боку ми вирішили подивитися на
підготовку тих людей які здійснюють
навчальну літературу бо експертиза
навчальної літератури теж
той чинник який забезпечує якість дуже
часто сприймають експертизу як оце щось
таке карательне яке має вплинути на
навчальну літературу сказати що вона
погана або добра ні
експорт здійснюючи експертизу має
показати всі позитивні риси даної
навчальної літератури і підказати дещо
необхідно підправити щоб дійсно
покращити ці цю навчальну літературу і
для цього був розроблений курс
називається Школа
експертів освітнього контенту він ще не
відкритий вище його не побачите але
скоро ми відкриємо його вже завершується
його
завантаження що це за курс А це курс
який ми створили не просто Скажем так за
допомогою фінського проекту на створення
цього куртку курсу ми запросили своїх
колег друзів Я маю на увазі ми як
інститут тих людей які брали участь в
розробленні державних стандартів і
початкової освіти і базової освіти Тобто
ми хочемо щоб всі люди які будуть
здійснювати експертизу Ну тільки
підручники але модельних навчальних
програм посібників почули безпосередньо
з перших вост від розробників що таке
державний стандарт і по кожній галузі
тобто якщо це експерт комісії яка
аналізує навчальну літературу з
математики Вона має Вони мають почути
Саме від розробників математичної
освітньої галузі що вони закладали цю
галузь і ви як вона має відобразитися в
навчальній літературі тому ми дуже
вдячні всім хто долучився он всій залі
присутня напевно половина наших авторів
в нас 30 тем і половина людей напевно я
зараз не рахувала Ну десь половина людей
присутня в залі багато сьогодні
спікерами були і виступали перед вами я
не буду оголошувати весь список я просто
можу когось загубити щоб не образити
коли курс буде відкритий там буде все
видно А програма Ми теж довго до не Але
чесно кажу це була якась така моя мрія
яку я не знала чи буде вона в житті
втілена чи ні але я кажу що мрії мають
збиватися так от одна з моїх мрій
збулася це проект буде Ми до нього довго
йшли програму ми створювали спільно у
нас в інституті схвалили вченої ради
крім того кожен хто пройде Цей курс
успішно це означає що всі хто його
прослухають будуть мати ну Скажем так
можливості бути експертом ні отримують
сертифікати Вчителі можуть його
використовувати як підвищення
кваліфікації то це розроблена як
програма підвищення кваліфікації на один
є КТС поки що ми хочемо через цей курс
коли ми його запустимо вже в роботу щоб
пройшли всі члени експертних комісій
чинних на сьогодні а потім відкрити
доступ до всіх бажаючих тобто щоб коли
ми будемо затверджувати новий склад
оновлений склад експертних комісій там
були лише сертифіковані експерти от Така
наша мрія Дякую Анатоліївна
один із викликів з якими
який ми маємо в новій українській школі
це власне розроблення
навчальної програми або модельної
програми і ось тут кожен вчитель коли
почув фразу про те що отримає повну
автономію для того щоб розробляти власне
своє бачення відразу постало нове новий
виклик а відповідальність тобто чи буде
відповідати вчитель потім за результати
власне
створеної персонально
навчальною програмою чи модельною
програмою Я знаю що
пані Юлія Романенко одна з першої
тестувала інструмент який називається
конструктор навчальних планів і програм
має свій зворотний зв'язок як власне
конструктор може
забезпечити вчителю можливість власне
автономії так і по-друге бути на 100% в
внений що все те що закладено в
державному стандарті буде виконано за
рахунок цієї модельної чи навчальної
програми
Дякую за запитання В нас дуже мало часу
я хочу просто розставити деякі акценти і
якщо брати рейтинг викликів
ми говорили Да що це і навчальна
література і побудова шкільної команди
то я одним із викликів назвала би той
який перекочував зі старої української
школи в нову якщо ви зі мною
погоджуєтеся дайте знати Я думаю що це
Битва за години
шкільній програмі і в освітній програмі
тому що
Розподіл годин між предметами між
галузями це той
камінь спотикання об який зіткнулися
починаючи від розроблення державного
стандарту і закінчуючи власне і
навчальною програмою коли вчитель
починає між темами ділити години між
різними курсами і предметами так от
Якщо говорити про практичну реалізацію
то будь-яка
концептуальна річ як От наприклад
автономія закладу або Академічна Свобода
вчителя вона неможлива без реальних
практичних інструментів які полегшать цю
справу і допоможуть і вчителеві і
шкільній команді і керівникові закладу
освіти реалізувати цю автономію так от
власне в цьому конструкторі який
складається Тепер уже розрісся він
спочатку був просто конструктор програм
а потім з'явився конструктор планів які
стосуються саме освітньої програми
закладу і тих розподілів годин так от
саме завдяки конструктору розробленому
за підтримки з проекту навчаємося разом
і шкільна команда може реалізувати свою
автономію від вибудувавши всі компоненти
освітні в освітній програмі і так само
вчитель або беручи за основу затверджену
модельну програму яка має гриф
Міністерства і розробляючи там або на
основі модельної або власну навчальну
програму він може повністю бути
впевненим тому що цей цифровий
інструмент в якому закладено всі
результати навчання з державного
стандарту в якому закладено всі правила
побудови освітньої програми згідно з
нормченного законодавства це інструмент
дає змогу і реалізувати автономію І
власне бути впевненим у тому що всі ідеї
нової української школи буде реалізова
но і на рівні освітньої на рівні
навчальної програми дякую пані Юля І на
завершення дуже короткий рефлексія одним
словом Що на вашу думку може 100%
вплинути на якість освітнього середовища
в наступному циклі власне реформи нової
української школи коли ми говоримо про
сьомий дев'ятий клас
одне слово одне слово
я б сказала прийняття
прийняття Тобто це вже є мотивація і
бажання і прийняття тому що якщо ми
будемо розуміти
[музика]
наскільки це потрібно наскільки це
ціннісно і наскільки це не швидко Я
думаю що
все у нас вийде але прийняття тобто не
супротив а прийняття дякую пані Оксано
зарахували як одне слово
пане Іване У мене два слова Я думаю що
на цьому етапі Де ми зараз є це має бути
горизонтальна підзвітність без цього
неможливо працювати в команді і
готовність до конструктивного конфлікту
якщо ви всередині не будете сперечатися
в своїх командах то це або фальшива
згода або це взагалі нерозуміння що
відбувається тому конструктивний
конфлікт і горизонтально підзвітність
Пані Олено Дякую пане одне слово і воно
звісно буде в напрямку навчальної
літератури апробації
Супер дякую мотивований вчитель
одне слово це тяглість
чудово давайте подякуємо нашим спікерам
панельної дискусії і Запрошуємо усіх на
каву паузу і повернемося до наступної
частини нашої конференції
раз два Шановні колеги Доброго дня всім
Ще раз дякую що повернулись цікава пауза
А зараз у нас буде дискусійна панель я
гадаю дуже цікава панель
щодо питань професійного розвитку
вчителів мудрувати його будемо моя
колега Наталя Софії
наша з кластеру один щодо професійного
розвитку вчителів прошу
колеги Вітаю Дякую що повернулися вчасно
знаю що вже кінець дня і все ваші і ваші
слідкувати за регламентом за часом
смішна Така трошки історія пригадалася
ви знаєте в нас кожного тижня проходили
щотижневі такі наради і наш компонент
саме професійний розвиток педагогів
завжди я починала перша і з цього
Сьогодні я тебе себе спіймала на тому що
ми фактично майже завершуємо тому що ще
Дмитро після нас але це був також
цікавий і є цікавим досвідом
я насправді доєдналася до проекту у
19-му році Але я думаю що багато хто з
вас пам'ятає що ви фактично в статусі
всеукраїнського фонду крок за кроком
починали перші тренінг для тренерів у
17-му році і тому такий здійснився
плавний перехід від знову ж таки
тренінгу від професійного розвитку до
фінського проекту і цю панельну дискусію
ми будемо вести вдвох тому щоб за перший
компонент власне відповідала моя фінська
колега туя лаурен радниця проекту яка
була із самого початку проекту і я
впевнена що вона зробила би все щоб бути
зараз разом з нами і до ви що ви всі
пам'ятаєте тую зараз свої побачите на
екрані і я пізніше трошки передам її
слово і сьогодні нашими спікерами
спікерками учасниками нашої панельної
дискусії а власне є учасники які
безпосередньо брали участь у проекті і
ми вирішили побудувати нашу дискусію
Таким чином щоби
поговорити які вже вплив мав проект на
різні складові на різні його складові і
саме головне що як нам забезпечити
життєздатність сталість проекту
поширення тих результатів про які ми вже
говорили і говоримо і будемо говорити і
щоб не повторювати те що вже написано
звертаю вашу увагу до прекрасного
буклету який був створений нашими
комунікаційними колегами і ви побачите в
першому компоненті професійний розвиток
педагогів побачити цифру скільки було
видів діяльності активностей проведено
скільки було педагогів охоплено саме
головне А у кожному компоненті містяться
qr-коди де ви можете перейти на
прекрасні ресурси зокрема в нашому
компетенті було створено чотири
онлайн-курси і ви можете перейти тому я
не буду дуже зупинятися на цьому І
власне представлю наших учасників нашої
дискусії я буду так по порядку Отже
ліворуч в мене сидить
пан Ігор бощак
Ігор Миколайович є
кафедри початкової та дошкільної освіти
завідувач кабінету розвивальних
технологій факультету педагогічної
освіти Львівського національного
університету імені Івана Франка а пани
Ігор він доєднався
в той час коли проект почав працювати із
закладами вищої освіти тобто в 20-му
році і на жаль нам не прийшло нам не
довелося не було можливості працювати
офлайн тобто одразу
всі почали працювати в онлайн Але тим не
менше і це буде цікаво почути от власне
порівнюючи з досвідом які мали інститути
післядипломної педагогічної освіти так
наскільки оця онлайн нова програма вона
була ефективною наскільки вона була
ефективною і навіть за такий короткий
час що вдалося досягнути як планується
далі поширювати ці результати А
наступний наш учас це пані Наталя
гальчевська
тренерка викладачка Вінницької академії
безперервної освіти пані Наталії також
експерткою із сертифікації і
супер-візерка нової української школи
пані Наталя була долучна до проекту від
самого початку і коли ми вчора з туї
говорили про учасників то я сказала що
вона так так каже Я пам'ятаю я пам'ятаю
цю Наталю тому що з Наталією З пані
Наталією ми були так починаючи ще я тую
бачу тут ще
із 17-го року і також з великим з
великою приємністю хоче представити пані
Наталію авшенюк професорка
докторка-педагогічних наук завідувачка
відділу зарубіжних систем педагогічної
освіти і освіти дорослих інституту
педагогічної освіти і освіти дорослих
імені Івана дзясюна Національної
академії педагогічних наук України пані
Наталя долучилася до проекту якраз як
учасниця
робочої групи з планування цієї
складової роботи із закладами вищої
освіти пані Наталя дуже багато працювала
дуже багато всі дуже багато працювати
але
брала участь у розробленні професійного
стандарту вчителя в мене на недавній
сесії минулі сесії ми говорили про
професійний стандарт керівника закладу
освіти але власне в цьому стандарту
передував професійний стандарт вчителя і
це логічно тому що професійний розвиток
педагогів так він без
сумніву пов’язані з цими питаннями Ну і
звичайно я з великою радістю хочу
передати слово для привітання і для
короткого огляду все-таки нашого
компоненту це
той лаурен
Ниці Фінляндія прошу туя будь ласка
туя вас не чути туя
Наталія Дуже дякую Люба Наталія вітаю
шановні гості любі колеги для мене
справжня честь бути
частинкою цієї спільноти І робити свій
внесок у заключну підсумкову конференцію
навчаємось разом в рамках кластеру один
ми сконцентрувалися на власне посиленні
підготовки вчителів до впровадження
нового стандарту і наші основні заходи
це підготовка та навчання тих хто
навчає вчителів також іппо і у ми діяли
також в рамках 24 пілотних університетів
де у нас був наголос все ж таки на
педагогічному навчанні майбутніх
вчителів знову ж таки Приблизно 50 спів
тренерів ми брали участь і з і ПТО і
знову ж таки пілотні університетичні
університети котрі брали участь котрі
завершили наш довго
нашу довготривалу модульну програму на
додачу до цього ми провели цілий ряд
тематичних тренінгів та семінарів
вебінарів і загалом приблизно
2600 учасників вчителів викладачів котрі
готують майбутніх вчителів тренерів
взяли участь у таких заходах і як
висновок хочу сказати що що ця частина
цієї тривалої роботи котру перервала
пандемія ковід і коли на жаль втрутилася
війна все ж таки ми залишалися на
зв'язку ми все впроваджували і наша
мережа в рамках цього проекту була
дійсно як найкраще зорганізована і
це дуже така активна професійна мережа
Хочу зазначити усі наші тренінги
відштовхувалися від
від власне поточних актуальних потреб і
безумовно за контексом співпадали із
реформою нуш та були погоджені з
найкращими практиками фінської освіти
наших тренінгів та контенту Отож це
педагогіка початкової школи класи від
першого до четвертого інклюзивна освіта
включаючи
диференційоване викладання оцінювання
розробка освітніх програм оцінка
інтегрованих предметів у класах п'ятий
шостий і кт тобто інформаційні
комунікаційні технології у педагогіці
менторство
майбутніх вчителів психосоціальна
підтримка учнів та вчителів і Хочу
зазначити що власне було обрано
системний підхід до таких тренінгів
котрі завжди базувалися на доказових
даних і в результаті таких тренінгів та
в результаті зібраного зворотнього
зв'язку нами було розроблено
ряд високоякісних онлайн навчальних
ресурсів для вчителів для
викладачів педагогічних університетів
навіть для батьків учнів і усі ці
матеріали є доступними у нуш хаб і на
платформі Едера Отож на додачу Ми також
підтримали системний
системний професійний розвиток вчителів
через забезпечення
відповідних
семінарів з
концепції центрів професійного розвитку
постійного професійного розвитку ми
провели також опитування
щодо пілотної програми по добровільній
сертифікації вчителів на додачу до цього
було проведено щорічні засідання і з
міністерством науки та освіти і головами
знову ж таки освітніх закладів на місцях
з тим що ви обговорювати
поступ та рух вперед шкільної реформи і
Наталії будь ласка підхопіть та
Продовжіть
як ми будемо продовжувати ви знаєте Мені
дуже було також приємно коли на минулі
пленарні ці дискусії пані Тетяна коли
завершувала дискусію щодо навчального
середовища і закінчували всі по одному
слову якби один із чинників успіху
сказали умотивований вчитель і рада що в
нас такі також відбувся перехід до
вчителя І я також ще пригадала свого
часу єврокомісця коли
розробила рекомендації щодо якості
освіти Вона назвала три основні
компоненти це
зміст освіти тобто стандарти підручники
посібники другий компоненти взаємодія
педагога з учасниками освітнього процесу
і третій компонент напевно Юрій
Терещенко тут якраз
підтримує що це саме власне моніторинг
тобто які дані ми збираємо і на основі
яких ми приймаємо стратегі рішення і
коли запитали десь в дискусії які вже
компонент є найважливіший то виявилося
що все-таки взаємодія тобто вчитель
наскільки вчитель мотивований наскільки
я вчитель компетентний пані Наталія Я би
хотіла попросити вас прокоментувати
власне от
напевне не те що чому чому наш компонент
підготовка педагога просто для
підтвердження Чому це так важливо Дякую
щиро дякую Шановні колеги рада вітати
всіх присутніх і також щиро дякую
організаторам за те що надали можливість
так коротенько відреафлексувати свою
участь у цьому проекті яка тривала також
ну практично від самого початку ось і
залучена я була також і як мені
пощастило бути і
як би експертом з розроблення тих чи
інших підходів до реалізації навчального
проекту а також і бути безпосереднім
учасником всіх тих тренінгів які з
великою людей зністю проводили для нас
фінські експерти І от власне якщо навіть
починати від сьогоднішньої рефлексії то
в мене теж таке виникло поєднання з
наших учасниками попередньої панельної
дискусії Ось але я також звернула увагу
на те єдине слово яке сказала керівниця
гімназії східних мов та про те що що
надає Ну тут можна сказати так щоб надає
вмотивованості вчителю якраз оте
прийняття І власне готуючись до Ну
сьогодні до сьогоднішнього виступу нашої
такої розмови я якраз і згадала про те
також іще такий один момент що
опрацьовуючи ну взагалі за своєю
діяльністю працюючи з багатьма
такими
цікавими міжнародними дослідженнями
помітили І власне це підтверджують
багато експертів у своїх
роботах і це ми говоримо про організацію
економічного співробітництва і розвитку
про Юнеско вони якраз роблять такі
Висновок про те що
жодні
якби внесення навіть фінансові ресурси
не можуть забезпечити отієї успішності
учнів їх навчання і всіх інших
пов'язаних цих моментів як
вмотивованість і професіоналізм вчителя
тобто власне звідки ж береться ця
мотивація звідки береться
Це бажання і прагнення робити те що
Фрейд колись ще в далекому 1937 році
характеризуючи певні види діяльності він
до речі професію вчителя як педагогіку
він назвав неможливою професією чому
Тому що це як він на його переконання це
та професія в якій ти ніколи не знаєш до
кінця наскільки успішним буде твоя
діяльність і результати які ти можеш
досягнути власне
тут можна говорити про те що
будь-які запропоновані трансформації
будь-які
реформування і зміни будуть успішними
лише тоді якщо вчитель на своєму
особистісному рівні це все з
інтероризує тобто коли він все це
зробить своєю особистісною цінністю коли
він зрозуміє що він
[музика]
усвідомлює все це коли він зрозуміє що
Навіщо це потрібно і як йому робити
роботи і ось цього власне і виростає
мотивація другим таким моментом цієї
мотивації також є переконання вчителя що
він не один він не залишився наодинці
тобто що він має певний
такий пол людей які його підтримують І
власне ця спільнота ця підтримка вона не
обмежується лише закладом освіти в якому
вчитель Працює Так Тобто це не лише
батьки учні це не лише оті основні
стихолдер заради яких вчитель працює А
це значно ширше коло і ось з цієї точки
зору хочу сказати що оці всі такі от
підвалинки про які тільки що сказала
Вони працюють на отой професіоналізм
вчителя який і є отим чинником успішних
реформ в яких ми і хочемо і прагнемо і
які забезпечують їх сталість і тяглість
І власне
от власне повторюся будучи і експертом і
учасником цього проекту можу сказати що
власне Він якраз і
максимально на мою точку зору
забезпечував ось для вчителя оцю
можливість
постійного професійного зростання і
розвитку і постійної рефлексії тобто на
мою точку зору отаким одним із
найбільших
надбань Да і здобутків цього проекту це
якраз є те що вчителі і ті тренери які
були які готувалися для того щоб вчителі
далі навчати те що вони ви працювали
тобто набували компетентностей
рефлексивного практика Тобто ми постійно
працювали і постійно ставили собі
питання і відпрацьовували їх на нас
вчили тому як рефлексувати кожного
практичного завдання і
а також хочу сказати що ось і туя
перечислила чимало інструментів яких е-е
цей проект надав освітянам і можливості
для розвитку і можливості для того щоби
цей проект проник не лише Тобто ми
говоримо тобто не лише у сферу
підвищення кваліфікації а також і в
сферу підготовки вчителя І отакими от
об'єднувальним інструментом на мою точку
зору і також досить важливим
таким здобутком це власне є розроблений
згаданий пані Наталію професійний
стандарт вчителя бо він якраз і є
унікальним в нашому освітньому і
професійному середовищі тому що
розроблене він не лише з урахуванням Ну
скажімо і на основі компетентнісного
підходу який До речі сповідує фінська
освітня система а і з отією можливістю
розвивального потенціалу щоб надати
вчителю можливість для самоідентифікації
своїх потреб своїх інтересів і своїх
можливих подальших планів на розвиток Ну
і також для того щоб рухатися і
професійно кар'єрними щаблями от На мою
думку власне
це все І забезпечує нам успішність
тяглість і вмотивованість всіх нас з
вами в тому щоб ці започатковані реформи
продовжувати Дякую дуже пані Наталя
Вінницька академія безперервної освіти
як і всі інші заклади післядипломної
педагогічної освіти безпосередньо
працюєте з вчителями тими критичними
рушіями змін про які ми тільки що
говорили пані Наталю який вплив залишив
проект на роботу на вашу роботу на
роботу вашого інституції Я думаю що це
не буде також подібне і для інших
закладів післядипломної освіти дякую
пані Наталю
власне у післядипломну освіту
імплементація афінського досвіду я себе
трішки підправлю Ось тут я погоджую з
пані лілією михайлівною яка уточнювала
можливо не зовсім проімплементацію
йдеться можливо справді
скажімо така творча імплементація така
інтеграція на українському ґрунті Бо у
нас теж досить добротний грунт
розпочалась ще з
2019 року і ось ми нагадували що саме ми
тренери для тренерів нової української
школи
представники
інститутів на той час після дипломної
освіти
власне системи підвищення кваліфікації
педагогічних працівників і нам пощастило
В цьому були першими здобувачами
навчання у проєкті навчаємось разом
знаєте я не втримаюсь і все таке
переповім про ті наші враження від
перших зустрічей з нашими ефінськими
партнерами бо власне пережили тоді
досить яскраві розючі емоції і це було
таке подарування така заінтригованість
Можливо навіть Ну такий допитливий
інтерес це була мотивованість Це була
схвильованість
і звичайно глибока вдячність вдячність в
першу чергу за високу довіру до нас до
українського вчителя до нової
української школи від
експертів однієї з найпотужнішої
найуспішнішою найефективнішої освітньою
системою яка вже себе задекларували яка
вже має результати
освітні результати
І
власне можливо мені так видається що
саме відтоді запустилися оті
трансформаційні зміни у нашу
післядипломну освіту тобто таке
відбулось переосмислення таке Я б
сказала якісне перезавантаження
Такий чарівний рефреймінг
перепрограмування нашого
наших поглядів на досить усталені до
цього звичні для нас але дуже важливі в
освіті речі
впродовж чотирьох років бо власне 2019
року ми так потужно працювали і впродовж
чотирьох років з нами було проведено це
лише з тренерами для тренерів нової
української школи було проведено дев'ять
активних навчальних сесій було надано
величезну кількість
ресурсів і це і друковані це цифрові
ресурси це доступ до платформи створеної
для інтерактивного навчання це власне
такий потужний просвітницький
інфопростір Тобто ми мали велику
підтримку у цьому процесі і тому ті
зараз трансформаційні процеси зміни які
досі відбуваються і будуть відбуватись
Звісно що
скажімо великою мірою ми завдячуємо
цьому і проєкту навчаємось разом і
скажімо от ще Хочу додати таке
намагалась підвести якусь статистику
хотілося б все-таки знаєте сказати про
якусь кількість тих на комусь на кому
цей ефект вже розповсюдився Хто активно
впроваджує але насправді це ну мабуть
неможливо зробити бо за ці роки теми
були інтегровані в освітні програми
підвищення кваліфікації у програми
навчання і тренерів нової української
школи і супер-візорів і експертів
сертифікації і учасників сертифікацій І
до речі
педагогів з наших пілотних шкіл тобто
насправді маємо процес який десь
подібний до ефекту кола кола на воді от
ті концентричні кола які лише
розширюються
Ну і звичайно Дякуємо за затікала точно
будемо їх збільшувати розширювати дякую
пані Наталю Пане Ігоре Ви доєдналися
трошки пізніше 20-му році нас не було з
вами жодних офлайн заходів але все ж
таки віриться Хочеться вірити що проект
також залишив по собі певні зміни що
вдалося після проекту можливо
започатковані нові програми так як нам
читали фінський експерт і так по
створенню освітніх програм тобто зараз
слово вам Дякуємо Ще раз дякую за
запрошення
університетів за запрошення
університетів до кола проектних
учасників
за те що і за гнучкий підхід який
сьогодні згадувався
він в нашій ситуації був реалізований
тому що Ми готувалися потрапити через
конкурс в цей проект Але виявилося що
візьмуть всіх як бонусом бо все буде
онлайн і
цей момент гнучко підходу а другий
момент що
ніби видавалося що були лекції
але всі вебінари які проводилися
фінськими викладачами вчителями
експертами вони всі були інтерактивні бо
ми
постійно рефлексували над завданнями над
темами які нам фінські колеги
пропонували до обговорення і постійно
про це думали і рефлекси вже сьогодні
звучала кілька разів я би ще додав до
рефлексії уміння рефлексувати і це для
нас
ця навичка яку ми мусимо студентам
передати
я би додав ще одну навичку як
як професійну професійну професійну
скарбничку в професійному ліску для нас
для викладачів для студентів ну я
сподіваюсь що вчителі будуть нас
підтримувати в цьому на практиках це
спостереження
професійність у спостереженні за
процесом який іде у класі
предметом чи дисципліною з конкретним
учнем з конкретною проблемою і це дуже
важлива навичка спостерігати я би якщо
зважати на якусь валізку То сказав би
спостереження і рефлексії це дуже
важливі речі і
до університетських результатів Я просто
би додав те що Університет може робити
Ми намагаємося ми створили простір
вирішили дві кімнати з килимами з
меблями відповідними
проводимо заходи з іншим університетами
заходи з
викладачами нашого цілого університету
який займається
середньою освітою тепер ланкою базовою
школи
на рівні дисциплін предметів курсів
намагаємося впроваджувати підходи які
популяризуються в ноші Ну і Найбільше це
практика
і напевно цим так трохи підсумую і знову
ж таки Ланку запущу це звернення до шкіл
є таке популярне слово вищій у світі з
тих холдери дуже всім користуються Я
кажу заінтересовані сторони і я би казав
школам ставати заінтересованими
сторонами школи які були пілоті які
пройшли добрі курси в цьому проекті щоб
не ставало заінтересованими сторонами у
підготовці вчителів і хорошими базами
практики
Дякую Пане Ігоре і принагідно Ну не можу
не згадати власне ці команди так
командний підхід і дійсно воно найбільше
проявилось коли проводилися тренінги
програми вебінарів по наставництву коли
ми по педагогічній практиці де власне це
наставництва проявляється повній мірі і
ми попросили щоб це були не лише
керівники педагогічної практики з боку
університетів але й керівники практики з
боку шкіл і навіть приємно що сьогодні
до нас команда Кривий Ріг Так пані Люда
лисогор дві Пані Олено Вибачте я зараз
прізвище Не скажу і вибачте кого я ще не
скажу Бо ну так час обмежений вдалось
поспілкуватися якраз і приїхали також
командою це також дуже хороший такий
можна сказати результат так само проекту
питання до туї якщо туя чує нас чи чує
то я на зв'язку коли починався проект
багато хто запитував чому саме фінський
досвід і відповіді були десь на поверхні
тому що дійсно фінська освіта показує
високі результати в міжнародних
порівняльних дослідженнях саме учні
показують
високі результати в міжнародних
порівняльних дослідженнях А мене
цікавить ту я питання до вас наскільки
ви відчули що фінський досвід він дійсно
суголосний з концепцією нової
української школи чи відчули це
ЄС так безумовно безумовно Наталія хочу
сказати що
ось таке засвоєння певних уроків від
фінської педагогіки фінської освітньої
системи власне в цьому була ідея коли
тільки народжувався наш проект
коли Ми планували нашу співпрацю і з
Україною і Пані Лілія гриневичко треба
була тоді міністр освіти та науки у той
час була справді ключовою особою в
рамках цього процесу Тобто ми дійсно
дуже вдячні пані лілії зокрема і ідея
була не просто скопіювати фінську
практику фінського освітню систему але
ідея була у тому щоб збагатити нову
українську школу реформу нуш саме
найкращими практиками Фінляндії котрі є
започаткованими на доказових даних і
наші тре із університету гельсінським а
також із школи підготовки Віки а також є
фінського фінської агенції з питань
освіти намагалися дійсно викладати як
практичні теорії вчителя так і саме
необхідність збору відповідних даних на
основі досліджень і так вони дійсно
висвітлювали все це в рамках усіх своїх
тренінгів семінарів чому саме Фінляндія
власне тому що концепція нуш справді
була заснована на тих самих принципах
якісна освіта для усіх права людини
демократичні цінності демократичні
принципи такі як орієнтованість на учня
освітньої програми з орієнтовані на
компетентності і оце серед ось
наскрізних ключових компетентностей та
цінностей
на котрий ми покладалися і котрі є
однаковими у Фінляндії та Україні хочу
якраз наголосити на таких важливих
компетентностях як критичне мислення
медіаграмотність та власне
вміння навчатися впродовж цього життя і
я впевнена що українські батьки та учні
усвідомлюють
за які цінності Вони борються і які
цінності Вони захищають зараз щиро дякую
і тепер напевне спільне запитання до
всіх тому що зараз напевно найбільше нас
цікавить як же ж нам забезпечити
життєздатність сталість результатів
проекту їх поширення Пане Ігоре почну з
вас тому що як ви сказали що у вас було
небагато тільки 24 заклади вищої освіти
і так сталося що онлайн формат дозволив
не не зупинятися на результатах конкурсу
а залучити всіх але це все-таки тільки
24 так от Як ви бачите поширення цих
ресурсів цих результатів які
Ваш університет так само як і так
досягнули будь ласка
тільки коротко
То всіх про це вже сьогодні згадували
тому дуже коротко про ресурси які
підготовлені в межах проекту про
хаб який нуж хап який організований це
дуже доречний потрібний необхідний
ресурс а друга напевно буде ідеєю
може б навіть поза проектом бо не
потребує проектної діяльності це робота
в професійних освітніх спільного та
оскільки
поки що це не формалізовано то
університет чи університетські викладачі
самостійно можуть
пробувати організовуватися в такій
спільноти і вирішувати ті проблеми які
наприклад стоять перед освітніми
програмами акредитація цих програм
інноваціями і
проблемами чи труднощами чи гарними
ходами у застосуванні підходів нової
української школи у системі вищої освіти
Дякую пане Ігор пані Наталю я скажу
коротко інвестувати вмотивованого
вчителя який
у підготовку навіть мотивованого вчителя
який здатний
якісно творчо працювати
професійно зростати і який точно буде
відшуковувати ось той якісний контент
Яким є наприклад
переданий нам від наших фінських друзів
нас не Я вважаю що цей проект чи має
бути досить добре
капіталізований Да Тобто його досвід
треба напевно ще так кажуть зробити
певний погляд зверху і чітко продумати
навіть на такому концептуальному можливо
рівні І так далі все ж таки які наслідки
довгострокові наслідки цього проекту
можуть бути і що потрібно Ну скажімо ще
які паростки Да в подальшого цього
всього можуть вирости із тих результатів
які вже на сьогодні досягнуті це перше
Ну і друге Ніщо так не об'єднує колег як
поширення кращих практик да свого
досвіду тому на мою думку також ми
проговорювали це попередньо варто
напевно започаткувати таку такий
майданчик таку платформу Да яка б діяла
постійно тобто дебиці об'єднані
професійні спільноти де би ми всі могли
ділитися цим досвідом і принаймні хоча
би раз в рік зустрічатися тобто мова йде
про якусь таку подію конференції чи
неконференції тобто про якусь таку
досить об'єднавчу таку спільну подію яка
би всіх нас могла надихати на те щоб
ставати кращими підвищувати якість нашої
освіти Ну і власне досягнути мені
здається того
результату даму яке можна сказати які
гасло цього проекту це власне підвищення
довіри суспільства до освіти тобто до
нас усіх із вами дякую дякую вам пані
Наталю і
панітує той думає що ще на зв'язку то я
а на вашу думку що ви порекомендували
як забезпечити сталість результатів
проекту
Я знаю що зараз
ми вже дійсно спродукували наскільки
багато ресурсів у нас по-перше дуже
багато людських ресурсів спів тренерів в
рамках іппо 20-4 пілотних університетів
і у нас знову ж таки дуже багато
онлайн-ресурсів напрацьовано Хочу
зазначити що людські ресурси матеріальні
ресурси вони по суті формують досить
такий потужний всеохотний пакет і я
сподіваюся що Міністерство подбає власне
про належне використання цих ресурсів з
усіма державними освітніми агенціями
інституціями щоб їх із цінністю
використовували і також хочу власне
зазначити ось цю зачеплену вами тему Це
ось ці мережі спільноти
освітян професіоналів у галузі осві ти
вони власне залишаються
і повинні залишатися активними для
подальшого розвитку для того щоб дійсно
була смуга ділитися усіма
найактуальнішими сучасними ресурсами
найкращими практиками
інструментаріями для вчителів
котрі власне Ми сподіваємося будуть
якнайкраще
розповсюджені для використання вчителями
тобто я дивлюся власне саме на питання
ось таких професійних спільнот як на
дуже важливе питання І вони також можуть
взяти на себе відповідно
відповідальність в рамках цього проекту
Ми пройшли через пандемію 19 і
зараз ця жахлива війна це ще триває Я
вважаю що
власне
освітяни професіонали спеціалісти в
галузі освіти показали свою стійкість
свою спроможність адаптувати підходи
своєї роботи та продовжувати надавати
підтримку
усім освітньому процесі Я абсолютно
переконана що власне ці люди і надалі
будуть відданими цій миті Дуже дякую
будемо вже підбивати підсумки і
завершувати
дуже вдячна всім нашим учасникам і
учасницям нашої панельної дискусії І
дійсно було сказано що
крім таких матеріальних ресурсів для
успіху для подальшого поширення
проекту які всі ми можемо знайти на нуш
хаб так дуже важливо цей людський
капітал ці людські ресурси які були
підготовлені як раніше ми говорили
Агенти змін так як таке також слово з
нашої з нашої історії щоб ми розуміли І
ми використовували і щоб зміцнювали
через власну ці професійні спільноти що
є дійсно також новим поняттям Я думаю що
в нас тільки розвивається можливо Ну
по-різному можемо говорити І думаю що
цей онлайн різні режими вони полегшують
все-таки оце спілкування обмін досвідом
друзі дякуємо вам за вашу увагу
Знаю що десь бачила що Літо це час для
всіх педагогів перезарядити свою
батарейку рік в нас був такий непростий
він не продовжується непростим ми
прийшли через усі плекаути невідомо яка
буде зима але наразі сьогодні і завтра
буде літо тому бажаємо всім відпочити
перезарядити
свою батарейки щоб з новими силами
наснами починати новий навчальний рік Ще
раз дякую учасницям нашого учасникам вам
дякую за увагу
Дякую колеги
тож прийшла пора до моєї презентації
практичні комунікаційні продукти для
освітян коли я прошу презентацію
а можна і на суфлер
тож я комунікаційний експерт проекту
навчаємось разом і
наш кластер який в якому я працюю він
займався комунікаціями і підтримкою
реформи нуш і
я трохи скажу про те
по-перше цієї презентації я хочу вас
залишити З думкою про те що комунікації
це не тільки про те що ми сказали і воно
пішло але й ці комунікації це і про
старість Тобто ми у наших комунікаціях
намагались бути максимально практичними
для вас для освітян і залишити після
наших комунікаційних компаній щось Що
вас що вам буде допомагати і у
майбутньому у вашій практиці І тому ми в
своїх комунікаціях ми завжди намагались
сформувати по-перше обізнаність і
позитивне сприйняття реформи і нуш і її
компонентів ми комунікували про те що і
як робить проект і допомагали
Департаменту
Департаменту комунікації Міністерства
освіти звісно під час
повна повного масштабної війни ми
змінили наші комунікації ми адаптували
комунікаційні кампанії змінили теми з
якими ми виходимо до наших аудиторій і
трохи скажу До кого ми звертались
по-перше ми звертались до декількох
аудиторій до освітян до директорів
закладів середньої освіти до учнів
вчителів батьків і намагались це робити
різними каналами комунікації різними
способами різними форматами от ви бачите
що ми робили і публікації і освітянських
медіа лонгріди так звані тобто великі
статті із практичними рекомендаціями і з
інфографіками з короткими рекомендаціями
практичними ми
робили і спецпроекти з суспільно-політи
намагались комунікувати до дітей до
батьків через соціальні мережі через
тіток і Інстаграмі і інші
ми за весь час нашої роботи провели
разом із мовним компонентом провели 12
медіа компаній у тому числі які були
направлені на різні аудиторії це і на
вчителів і на керівників закладів
середньої освіти і на загальну аудиторію
коли ми комунікували наприклад цінності
освіти і ми робили це Через декілька
платформ які Я закликаю вас
[музика]
відвідати і це наші основні канали
вебсайт нуш hub.org.ua наш канал на
Ютубі який ви можете знайти по пошуку
навчаємося разом та наші Facebook
сторінки навчаємось разом нова
українська школа та дружня школа і Крім
того ми розповсюджували наші
новини через нашої щомісячні дайджести
через електронну пошту І
як ми комунікували іще за допомогою
сторонніх каналів комунікацій через
освітянський ЗМІ як я і сказав
суспільно-політичні та інші
ну загально якщо сказати про наші
результати дуже коротко То
всі наші компанії охопили більше 15 млн
українців серед них більше двох
мільйонів освітян і з чим ми залишаємо
Ну от завершуємо проект це більше 65
відеоматеріалів із практи рекомендаціями
для освітян більше 100 різних буклетів
Та інфографік ми виготовили І ми також
виготовили в рамках однієї з компаній
професійні щоденники для вчителів про
які я згодом скажу
і про що кажуть нещодавні опитування які
були і наприкінці 22-го року і на
початку цього року про те що обізнаність
та розуміння громадськості щодо реформи
освіти та нуш зокрема вона вилізла І от
ви бачите що 82% респондентів вони
знають про реформу нуш
крім того позитивне сприйняття і роль
освіти у суспільстві вона по цих знову ж
таки опитуваннях вона зростає і крім
того
освітяни кажуть що вони повністю або
радше підтримують реформу і вчителі
директори і вони кажуть про те що вони і
знають про професійні стандарти нові які
були у тому числі завдяки нашому проекту
втілені в життя і Ну звісно реформування
освіти і нуш зокрема воно постійно ми
намагалися його постійно тримати у
інформаційному полі суспільства
Але дійсно під час війни трохи наша
комунікація мала змінитись
тож перший такий сталий продукт який ми
залишаємо і передаємо Міністерство
освіти це нужхаб нуш.org.ua це
веб-сайт який є збіркою всіх необхідних
матеріалів практичних матеріалів для
освітян який ми розробили
співробітництві з міністерством освіти і
з інститутом модернізації змісту освіти
та командою підтримки реформ і та
Європейським європейською громадською
організацією євро-5 антикіллайнс та
нашим
місцевим підрядником Active Media і цей
вебсайт Якщо ви на нього знайдете ви
можете знайти його qr-код у наших
буклетах який ми сьогодні роздавали він
складається із трьох частин Перша
частина середня яка називається
ukrainiansaport ніші А це каталог
освітніх матеріалів освітніх програм для
українців за кордоном які можуть знайти
їх в онлайні і навчатись у тому числі
безкоштовно по різних програмах і від
мови закінчуючи математикою та іншими
ресурсний центр це електронна бібліотека
нуш яку ми намагались напо
підручниками Посібниками методичними
матеріалами саме для вас і ви там
знайдете ті метод матеріали з усіх
предметів для закладів середньої освіти
Там буквально з першого по 11-й клас І
звісно сторінки проекту навчаємось разом
На якому На яких ви знаєте де наші
статті новини
та матеріали для освітян
приведу кілька прикладів що залишилось
після наших комунікаційних компаній це
наприклад після тартованої компанії
дружня школа а в рамках якої ми говорили
про те як створити
сучасне освітнє середовище ми розробили
3D тур е-е його теж ви можете знайти за
qr-кодом у вашому буклеті А цей 3D тур
теж розміщений на нашому наш Хабі і він
є такою знаєте
електронною демонстрацією того як може
виглядати сучасна школа і
в ньому Ми зібрали не тільки от
візуально познімали ну в Київських
школах щось але й ми зібрали
рекомендації в тому числі ДСТУ ДБН Тобто
Це стандарти державні за якими ви можете
користуватися і е-е продукувати свої
ідеї як створити сучасну освітнє
середовище в вашій школі і у тому числі
там же ви знайдете 34 відео і з
короткими рекомендаціями про те як
зробити Stem
stem-кабінет як реформувати
шкільну столову ви почуєте дітей які
кажуть про те що вони люблять їсти ну
тобто ми намагались намагались буквально
живо відтворити те що є у е-е
вже
хтось зробив і може поділитись своїми
досвідом тож прошу відвідати скануйте
qr-код і побачити дуже цікаві матеріали
в травій компанії професійний стандарт
вчителя ми е-е який ми адаптували під
час війни Ми почали її проводити ще до
війни але
адаптували під час війни ми запустили
цілу серію
статей лонгрід і у тому числі як я і
сказав раніше з інфографіками короткими
рекомендаціями практичними
ці longridi вже прочитала більше 40 000
часов освітян Приєднуйтесь ви А І
наприклад серед цих статей під час війни
ми змінили їх тематику і наприклад
зробили статті як залишаєшся у професії
який лайфхаки для вчителів які можуть їм
допомогти на період воєнного стану
залишитися професії і підтримувати
самого себе у ресурсному стані в тому
числі як працювати психологічну
стійкість як поводитись з дітьми під час
війни
як з ними говорити про стрес
Крім того в рамках цієї компанії ми
виготовили 1800 щоденників які
ці щоденники професійного розвитку вони
ми в нього включили практичні тести
рекомендації як втілити в життя в свою
роботу
професійний стандарт вчителя І наприклад
там
ті рекомендації які ми в тому числі і в
соцмережах публікували ми
і склали за допомогою експертів imzo ми
її включили цей щоденник і Наприклад
деякі з них допоможуть Навіть зараз
вчителю рухатись по своїй професії в
тому числі і ми побачили що ці щоденники
були дуже затребувані ми їх
наприкінці 22-го року розповсюджували
через 45 центів професійного розвитку та
інститутів післядипломної освіти Ми
побачили що вони дуже затребувані тому
ми їх завантажили ще на нуш хаб і за
qr-кодом у ваших буклетах ви їх тоже Теж
можете завантажити в електронному
вигляді і роздрукувати наприклад
Крім того в рамках цієї ж компанії ми
виготовили серію практичних відео з
поясненнями того які якими компетенціями
має
моє оперувати вчитель і теж ви їх можете
знайти у вільному доступі на нашому
YouTube каналі
таргетована компанія професійний
стандарт директорів
закладів середньої освіти в рамках якого
ми теж зробили і статті із практичними
рекомендаціями І цілу серію відео із
рекомендаціями як в наших фінських
експертів так і наших українських колег
які і тут присутні в тому числі які
рекомендували про те як створити команду
як управляти командою загальну
закладу загальної середньої освіти і так
далі І ці поради ми от бачимо Що
наприклад е-е один із постів які ми на
нашій facebook-сторінці опублікували як
директорові права дуже От і
компетентності нуш там на здається
травень цього року мав 9 000 переглядів
і зараз більше тож читайте і ви Заходьте
на наші Facebook сторінки
в рамках компанії цінності освіти із
компонентом відповідальні батьки ми
намагались прокоментувати про те що
освіта важлива освіта важлива не тільки
у мирний час але воєнний час і через
історії батьків дітей у тому числі
переселенців директорів шкіл які були
під окупацією в тому числі вчителів які
під окупації вийшли і все одно не
змінили професію а продовжують навчати
дітей ми намагались прокоментувати Для
загальної аудиторії про те що
освіта дійсно важлива не тільки у мирний
час але і воєнний час і
те історії цієї вони якраз показують про
те що українці Вони знають що навчатись
потрібно і навчати потрібне і навіть
отакий час
і в рамках цієї ж компанії ми робимо ще
доробляємо зараз
комікси які дуже в простому вигляді
розповідають про цінності освіти як
рівний доступ до освіти Академічна
доброчесність та інші
крім того завершується наразі кампанії
про державний стандарт базової середньої
освіти теж Ми
зробили цілу серію відеороликів які
розповідають про те що таке типова
освітня програма які є освітні програми
для нуш які є Що є діяльністьним
підходом до навчання крім того через
тих же вчителів які е-е
навчають і намагаються комунікувати про
те як вони навчають в тому числі через
тіток наприклад всім відомий оцей
вчитель з Тік току він намагається
комунікувати про те що таке оцінювання в
нуш Він навіть
розвінчує міфи про те що нуш не навчає
нічому а-а тому доєднуйтесь і ви
дивіться ці матеріа ли вони є в як на
наших Facebook сторінках так і на нашому
YouTube каналі
і крім того разом з нашими колегами з
інших кластерів ми розробили наприклад
от навчальні курси які у нас є
опубліковані вже на нужнабі тринавчальні
курси про ІКТ про
[музика]
Вибачте не бачу е-е і три навчальні
курси ми опублікували Просто у нас були
записи відео із
із наших вебінарів але ми захотіли
зробити так щоб ці вебінари пройшли не
тільки
ті люди які були під час цих вебінарів
розповсюдити для тих хто взагалі хоче їх
почути зібрали ці вебінари і зібрали їх
На одному сайті у тому числі із
додатковими матеріалами презентаціями
які можна скачати подивитись і знову ж
таки і не тільки на сайті на нашому але
й на YouTube каналі а-а крім того разом
з третім кластером ми
зняли
за допомогою фінських експертів відзняли
фінських директорів шкіл і
їх практичні рекомендації про те як вони
працюють які
вони є навички використовують які
управлінські стратегії вони
використовують і опублікували оцю серію
відео з п'яти відео е-е від фінських
директорів шкіл Ну і крім того всі ці 5
років Мої колеги от гіо е-е які на наш
копірайтер та Ліза наша
дизайнерка вони працювали як інтегровані
спеціалісти у комунікаційному
департаменті е-е Міністерство освіти
вони розробляли і писали безліч
комунікаційних візуальних матеріалів
прес-реалізів інфографік тобто все те що
ви могли бачити на сайті мон у такому
красивому вигляді все це розробляли Мої
колеги
за що їм Велике дякую і ви Я думаю теж
можливо і навіть користувалась цими
матеріалами А
з чим я хочу вас залишити з тим що
по-перше комунікації - це завжди і
дорога з двостороннім рухом Тобто ми під
час наших кампаній ми завжди
дослуховувались до нашої аудиторії ми
слухали ті коментарі які були на
соціальних мережах адаптувалися і це
була така знаєте командна можна сказати
робота тому ж давайте насолоджуватись
командною роботою як роблять ці українці
і можна запустити цей відеоролик
запустіть будь ласка
Ні це відеоролик має бути
цей відеоролик Який теж ви можете
побачити на нашому YouTube каналі ми
намагались прокоментувати про цінність
професії вчителя і підтримати вчителів
в мене все Дякую І наразі буде наступна
дискусійна панель підтримка партнерів
під час реалізації реформи нуш які буде
модерувати пан Роман Шиян і в ньому
будуть брати участь е-е наші е-е
партнери які
підтримували реформу нуш і допомагали і
здійсненню це представники центру
регіланда британської ради в Україні які
будуть онлайн освіторія теж буде онлайн
та Ед кемп прошу
Я ще попросив приєднатися до нас е-е
Юрка Наталя На жаль вже пішла і ну для
того щоб була повна картинка двоє
учасників у нас будуть онлайн
і ще одна
приєднається вона вже там паркується і
щойно Я з нею розмовляв
перш ніж розпочати я скажу те що я не
сказав з трибуни
на те питання яке я задавав яркові Що є
основним досягненням проєкту то моя
версія відповіді зводиться до того що
команда проєкту як самодостатня цінність
бо скажу вам по секрету не відразу
прийшло розуміння того що треба
формувати українську експертизу через
залучення координаторів
кластерів спочатку в парі з
фінськими колегами А в деяких випадках
згодом і самостійно
і це дуже важливий внесок я вважаю про
нашу реформу і я вже тут відзначив ту
таку унікальну роль
Юрка я ще До цього повернуся але також
Наталя Софійка була модераторкою
попереднього
попередньої панелі в парі з тую зробили
дуже вагомий внесок у розробляння цих
модулів для підвищення кваліфікації
вчителів і також Як ви побачили в
Вищу педагогічну освіту первинну
і
це це Важливо пам'ятати
і перш ніж розпочати дискусію і так по
порядку
розкопати з чого почалося Які в нас є
ґрунт під ногами і як ми можемо рухатися
далі я хочу запросити до слова онлайн
нашу колегу з
освіторії
Анну Сидорук
і я поясню чому Тому що Тут йшлося
сьогодні вже
Наталя казала про те що треба це
капіталізувати так От так склалося що що
зараз той пакет
матеріалів який
створювався коли ми заходили в п'ятий
клас
капіталізований на на платформі
освіторії тому що найкраща експертиза ну
первинна експертиза та яка
ну з перших вуст так би мовити була
зосереджена за кілька місяців до початку
пілотуваги до початку масової практики і
завдяки оцій співпраці ми змогли зайти в
масову практику базовій освіті і тому я
хотів би запитати вас анном про дві речі
по-перше
як це вдалося
от зібрати під на вашій платформі те що
на той момент які чинники от сприяли нам
у тому щоб це співпраця склалася і друге
як ми можемо надалі цим розпорядитися
тут я знаю є кілька версій Я хотів би
почути вашу як далі можна це
використати Дякую будь ласка
вітання пане Романе вітання колеги рада
бути з вами сьогодні
відповідаючи на перше запитання Романа
хочу сказати що для нас ось цей проєкт
реформи нуш він власне почався не
Минулого року а ще
2017-му коли ми долучилися до розробки
ще першого курсу початкової школи і для
нас на той момент це був такий перший
найбільший проект співпраці з державою
величезна честь ще більше
відповідальність і відповідно величезний
ентузіазм і ми змогли пронести в собі
всі ці складові і тому якраз зібрати
ключових експертів тих хто продовжував
вірити в реформу нуж попри все було
насправді не так вже й складно тому що
ми дуже і дуже цього хотіли тут викликом
було інакше це те що ми по суті
розпочали роботу над цим контактом в
весь такий розгар війни і тоді там
більшість донорів І взагалі всі учасники
освітнього процесу були зосереджені
максимально на таких гарячих питаннях
е-е
так тобто закривати гарячі питання які
його там зі школами з доступом арештою а
для нас було вкрай важливо все ж таки
продовжувати
реформу нової української школи попри
все для того щоб учні базової школи
також могли відчути на собі всі ті
переваги нуш от тому власне ми
Звернулися до тих експертів з ким
працювали довгий час хто розділяє
цінності нової української школи і разом
з формували програму нам допомогла пані
Лілія Гриневич зробити власне
ось цей правильний такий перехід від
курсу молодшої школи до курсу базової
середньої школи І власне від того ми вже
відштовхувалися маючи цю таку програму
основи далі вже безпосередньо працювали
з експертами їх було близько 30 і там
програма охопила ключові напевне такі
модулі ключові
як це правильно сказати компоненти нової
української школи для базової освіти І
звісно ж в наших подальших планах
продовжувати розвивати цей проект
під час 2022 року ми відзначали 100
тренерів які далі поїхали в регіони і
вже продовжували викладати проводити
тренінги для вчителів нуш в
безпосередньо в регіонах плюс вже понад
якщо не помиляюсь 25 тисяч вчителів
пройшли цей курс також на сайті
університет про який До речі якраз
згадував пан Роман І продовжують
навчатися Я знаю що багато хто з
вчителів запланував собі протягом літа
нам про це говорили на фесті що це одна
з таких задача на літо теж переглянути
курс пройти його пройти цю всю програму
на 30 годин на підвищення кваліфікації
тому вчителі продовжують навчатися в нас
теж є певні плани ми Очікуємо на
підтвердження підтримки проекту від
одного великого донора куди ми подалися
національним консорціумом І якщо все
складеться добре то відповідно у нас
буде новий виток в напрямку навчання
вчителів в межах реформи нова українська
школа тут є запит від держави
актуалізувати і дещо оновити
скажімо як зробити такий певний рефрешт
нуш по молодшій школі тому що за останні
роки все ж таки відбулося певне
просідання і відповідно максимально
макштабувати проект для базової старшої
школи
А можна задати вам уточнююче Запитання
Ви згадали про цей новий проєкт Я теж
про нього щось чув трохи я хотів би
власне дізнатися хто ще крім освіторії в
ньому буде залучений якщо це можна
сказати і як будуть розподілені ролі
власне В тій частині яка стосується
підвищення кваліфікації вчителів чи це
буде лише ваше
національний консор
ціум інформація тут в нас Ми зібрали ми
зібралися такими організаціями які вже
працюють давно в сфері
освітнього ринку дехто не дуже давно Але
є гарними експертами Це зокрема фонд
Київської школи економіки це проект
навчання для України це фонд save at -
це прожектор edcamp і освіторія ось
такий наразі в нас склад те що
стосується навчання вчителів нуш
безпосередньо в цьому консорціумі то тут
в нас є певний є певне бачення Як це має
відбуватися і ми дещо розподіляємо ці
ролі тобто на навчанням вчителів в
рамках ну ж буде безпосередньо займатися
освіторія тому що ми вже багато в цьому
напрямку зробили але також деякі
компоненти буде закривати edcamp і
навчають для України зокрема
Дякую і на цих словах я хочу запросити
приєднатися до нас на подіумі Олена
масалітіну з кем тобто в нас є в нашій
панелі беруть участь ще не менше двоє
представників цього консорціуму
А що ви скажете про те щоби повторити
сценарій початкової освіти Анна бо я
знаю що ви маєте там ще якісь наступні
зустрічі хочу вже закінчити з розмову з
вами і
повторити той підхід який був От
згаданий вам період початкової школи
коли курс Едера був обов'язково для всіх
хто заходить в нову українську школу як
як ви ставиться до того щоб цей курс
зробити обов'язково
насправді Це моя мрія і я думаю що
зокрема
один з компонентів чому реформа нуш
початкової школи тоді так вдалася тому
що була сильна політична воля пані лілії
Гриневич яка Ну яку називають мамою нуш
і тоді Був дійсно було прийняте рішення
що це обов'язково курс і без цього Ніяк
Так всі вчителі початкової школи мають
бути вчителями нуш А зараз
через певні законодавчі моменти зробити
його
прямо зараз наскільки мені відомо
обов'язково неможливо Але я думаю що за
певною волі Все можливо тому я вважаю що
так і має бути для вчителів базової
школи курс він повинен бути
обов'язковом всі вчителі мають пройти
цей це навчання і відповідно розділяти
ту методологію цінності які несе в собі
нова українська школа тому я про це
особисто мрію наші сервари все
витримають створимо групу підтримки Ми
вже знаємо як це робити коли ми робили
цей проект з едерою тому ми до цього
будемо готові і будемо дуже раді
пам'ятаєте Яка у вас там статистика на
сьогодні
скільки вже вчителів пройшло Цей курс по
молодшій школі це по 300 тисяч вчителів
або базовій понад 25 тисяч
але я пригадую як це було в початковій
школі коли пішов лист і в один момент
всі вчителі прийшли на платформу Едера і
були готові тому що прийшов лист це було
важливо для вчителів правда на мою думку
досі є ось цей інструмент він є робочим
тобто якщо є вказівка то відповідно
вчителі в обов'язковому порядку
навчається Мені здається що коли мова
йде про реформу ці інструмент варто
використовувати звісно має бути певна
Свобода щодо
інших напрямків підвищення кваліфікація
легше мова йде про реформу то на мою
думку тут має бути сильна рука технічно
не маєте ніяких перешкод для того щоб не
маємо абсолютно ми підготуємо
це реально дуже вам дякую Анна за вашу
участь
дякую
і на цих з цієї точки Я хотів би перейти
до вас хрестинам тому що я знаю що серед
оцих
асинхронних курсів є курс який був свого
часу був розроблений в проектом
демократична школа за підтримки
європейського центру wergeland
і він підкріплений також тренерськими
мережами які можуть його там
мультиплікувати комбінувати його з
офлайновими модулями розкажіть про це
більше ж на що ми можемо розраховувати з
вашого боку
це програма демократична школа почала
розробляти курси на підтримку
вчительської майстерності і
управлінських компетентностей власне
масові онлайн нові курси в 21-му році
21-му році вони почали з'являтись на
платформі Прометеус
мусимо сказати що ці ідеї онлайн довго
навчання в нас в програмі були давно і
коли на початку 20-го року ми проводили
дослідження як навчаються вчителі
наскільки вони готові навчатися онлайн
результати було доволі невтішними ми
бачили що треба буде дуже багато
працювати з тим щоб вчителі почали
навчатися онлайн і прихід
пандемії трошки всім В цьому плані
допоміг так вчителі почали вчитися
онлайн
І врешті в 21-22-му році ми розробили
цикл курсів на даний момент
станом на тиждень десь тому 114 тисяч
осіб були зареєстровані і трошки понад
40 тисяч
осіб отримують сертифікати цього циклу
курсів власне ми пробували цих курсах не
стільки йти від якихось
настільки говорити про політичні моменти
скільки перекладати політику на мову
практичних вмінь та
компетентностей вчителя та управління це
перекладати
ціннісні основи нуш на такі більш
практичні вимірні і
потрібні так на думку вчителів на думку
управлінців речі знову ж таки ми були
трошки
Ми зрозуміли так після того як почали
запроваджувати ці масові онлайн курси
Хоча вони користуються великою
популярністю крім попри те що немає
жодного листа і жодної рекомендації щодо
їхнього використання міністерством цифри
достатньо великі Але ми теж зрозуміли що
вчителі не отримують того що вони
найбільше хочуть через цей масові онлайн
нові курси і їм потрібно спілкування їм
потрібно взаємопідтримка їм потрібні
обмін досвідом і тому почали
впроваджувати фасилітовані курси на ці ж
тематики І власне там коли 30 осіб 20-30
осіб зустрічається впродовж там двох з
половиною місяців
пройшовши перед тим масовий онлайн-курс
обмінюючись досвідом виконуючи практичні
вправи отримуючи зворотній зв'язок ми
побачили що це набагато
корисніше Так набагато краще кращі
результати це дає вчителі Це набагато
більше оцінюють і знову ж таки ну на Ці
курси приходять ті вчителі їм потрібно
трошки більше ніж сертифікат бо
поклацати онлайн
тести чи якісь навіть складніші завдання
на наших курсах Ми якраз спеціально
відмовлялися від тестів йшли йдемо від
якихось таких трошки хоча б трішки
компетентнісних завдань наскільки
дозволяють платформи і можливості так то
все ж таки ну на нашу думку нашої
програми фасилітовані курси хоча
вимагають набагато більше ресурсу але є
найбільш набагато більш корисними і
вчителі їх більше люблять
Скажіть будь ласка трохи більше про
контент Тобто це йшлося про наскільки я
пам'ятаю ключові компетентності в такому
практичному вимірі згодом формувальне
оцінювання яке так формувальне
оцінювання ми тільки почнемо восени наш
веселітовані курси і причому маємо
формувальне оцінювання як для вчителів
так і для адміністрації шкіл і також ну
курс який ми цього що Так дякую за
запитання Бо якось мені це вискочило з
голови що в нас були свої плани на курси
які потрібні для підтримки нуш так Але
знову ж таки через пандемію зараз наш
найпопулярніший курс куди приходять там
понад тисячу вчителів ну під 2000 навіть
Я б сказала кожного набору це шкільне
життя онлайн де ми про онлайн педагогіку
з вчителями говоримо і тут Ми якось
пішли від зворотнього Ми почали робити
фасилітовані курси з першої ніяк не
можемо закінчити
масовий онлайн-курс Хоча зараз вже
здається їх з'явиться так достатня
кількість ось
то це також курси про розвиток
громадянських компетентностей про курси
для управлінців ми їх потрішки кожен раз
трішки змінюємо це компетентність на
навчання розвиток компетентностей
громадянських компетентностей парадовсів
але це більше такий акцент саме що таке
компетентність на навчання і теж
Працюємо з учнівським самоврядуванням
розвитком учнівського самоврядування в
школах отакий така тематика Дякую І от
ви розповідаєте і в мене тут флешбек
такий виникає мені нагадали колеги що
перший
вебінар з впровадження нової української
школи від від розпочався з Ірпіні рівно
шість років тому 4 липня
17-го року
Це був один виклик і Тобто це було за
рік до того як прийшов фінський проєкт
і коли фінський проект вже прийшов
тобто за рік після того восени 2018
спільно з проектом
демократична школа з командою Христини
тут присутня Тут взагалі Олена Шиян як
експертка європейського фонду освіти Ми
на базі центрального інституту вперше
зібрали експертів які
це були координатори з початкової освіти
а також ті хто мав найвищу
компетентність в гранді щодо
підприємливості і цифрової ключових
компетентностей Із залученням фахівців з
числа розробників державного стандарту
за підтримки європейського фонду освіти
Ми їм оце власне вперше
показали як можуть працювати ключові
компетентності через
результати навчання і навіть
продемонстрували першу версію
конструктора навчальних програм тут
присутні розробник Володимир
Іванов десь тут точно є
тобто Зараз існує нова версія до якої
можна звертатися Яка теж може бути
частиною підвищення
кваліфікації
і
тут я повернуся до
завершується свої спогади оцієї
кульмінаційною точкою яка сталася
навесні 2021 року
коли
виклик
перейти від початкової школи до
наступного етапу так той курс і
називався нова українська школа перехід
на наступний рівень така двозначність
рівень як базова освіта і рівень
нашого занурення в цю проблематику І от
тоді так по-справжньому вже почала
формуватися ця екосистема
тих провайдерів
суб'єктів підвищення кваліфікації
власне
присутні тут
і ті хто з нами онлайн ми ще зараз
повернемося до учасниці нашої панелі
онлайн
з яка представляє британську Раду тобто
був
Христина зі своїм проектом був Юрій який
представляв проект
навчаємось разом
і от 29
квітня оцей день коли світло гаслова в
країні див
завдяки унікальній підтримці з боку
Оксани Коваленко в міністерстві ми такі
розпочали і тоді були промовці від усіх
тих кого я зараз називаю з тури на
приєдналася Олена бег
далі
[музика]
був Олександр елькін теж серед тих
промовців які розпочинали цю цю фазу
впровадження нової української школи
була Христина Юрко тоді це ВІЛ от власне
тоді Юрко взявся все під свою
дорогенську паличку паличку і в одній
руці тримав її а в інші парасольку
фінського проекту і навколо цього
почалася оця оця
розбудова створення отих команд про які
сьогодні
згадували на попередній панелі
От і
власне Я хотів би попросити Юрко тебе
сказати кілька слів про те як нам чому
нам це тоді вдалося бо все насправді
було проти нас тоді
Дякую пане Романа складне запитання але
перш за все хочу сказати пролунало слово
парасолька Мабуть це
секрети успіху будь-якої системи яка
сьогодні працює в Україні і мабуть
освіта Сьогодні має
брати приклади збройних сил України які
працюють однією командою заради одного
результату у нас
під освітньою парасолькою дуже багато
партнерів і Щиро дякуємо усім тим хто
був разом поряд із проектом навчаємось
разом тому що спільними зусиллями ми
змогли
власне зробити старт який потребує
продовження І кожен фініш - це по суті
старт так як говорить класик тож які
уроки маємо сьогодні взяти у збройних
сил України власне це робота з командою
де чітко кожен розуміє власне якою
частинкою пазла є і без кого неможливе
зібрати повен пазл так
сьогодні ми розуміємо як важливо берегти
ресурси наших вчителів які працюють
24 на в абсолютно різних форматах
навчання і наскільки цінних цінним для
них має стати власне ті курси підвищення
кваліфікації які планує кожен із
партнерів
І
власне з розуміння того Наскільки мало
цього часу і наскільки важливо донести
до вчителя
засадний чи речі практичні кейси Мабуть
це буде запорукою продовження власне
реформи нової української школи і
створення ефективної системи завдяки
партнерам завдяки міжнародним
організаціям інститутом післядипломної
освіти які теж сьогодні мають стати
такими майданчиками синергії в кожному
регіоні дуже важлива також розуміти що
вчителі сьогодні потребують максимально
практи має підтримки
вони вже розуміють цінності і засади
нової української школи але тепер
потребують практичних кейсів для того
щоб
зрозуміти власне як реалізувати новий
державний стандарт і Мабуть це те
ключове завдання що яке стоїть Перед
кожним з партнерів в новому етапі
ми всі чекали як вчителі-практики чекали
власне як
і будь-які вчителі світу коли змінюється
освітня парадигма чекають методичної
підтримки чекають посібника для вчителя
чекають певних методичних інструкцій
критеріїв оцінювання тому власне
наступним кроком який має об'єднати усіх
швидко заповнити тих пазлів які їх
сьогодні не вистачає вчителю і таким
чином
досягнемо бажаного результату в другому
кроці
Дякую Олена
Я хотів би запитати вас про те
ну по-перше
згадували в рамках цього концерту який
аспекти ви могли на на себе плануєте на
себе взяти в рамках цього проекту із
зокрема про той легендарний двері бо я
пам'ятаю тоді зізнаюся що коли Я
запрошував до слова Олександра тоді
наприкінці квітня то я так майже
попросив його щоб якось провів не дуже
говорити бо він такий був табуйований на
той час Сашко звичайно трохи сказав про
нього але я на нього не гнівався
хоча фідбек там такий був невеличкий
тоді після цього
ми зараз стоїмо от Якщо порівняти це з
дворічною подіями дворічної давності
Добрий день і тим хто тут і хто дивиться
правильно розумію що оце відлік до того
моменту Коли наша карета перетвориться
на гарбуз
Ясно тоді я буду заступник Міністра
я перед тим як скажу про двері підведу
до нього хочу сказати про три такі
ключові речі на яких стоїть кемп у коли
говоримо про підвищення кваліфікації
особливо Зараз ми переконані що
завдяки тим змінам які відбулися і в
законі і в підзаконних ах в нас зараз є
широка можливість обирати де підвищувати
кваліфікацію як в який спосіб І от нам
здається особливо зараз дуже важливо щоб
йшлося не про кількість і бігти не туди
де ти побачиш або що тобі попадеться А
якраз через двері ми розпрацьовуємо
спеціальний інструмент для того щоб
допомогти кожному педагогу окремо ви
будете свою індивідуальну траєкторію
професійного зростання і допомогти
педагогічному колективу підійти до цього
питання комплексно тому що
Важливо щоб ті курси чи навчання які
приходять кожна людина в колективі могли
взаємопідсилювати взаємодоповнювати одне
одного і важливо розуміти можливо трьом
людям важливо то ти піти п'ятьом туди
щоб це був такий цілісний процес і от
якраз на національній платформі
професійного зростання advay зараз
добігає вже свого кінця завершення
інструмент який дає можливість всім хто
на цій А до речі махніть рукою мені будь
ласка хто передбачили
Дякую А хто вже там А не тільки чула я
дуже актуальна інформація зараз для
аудиторії ви правильні запитання ставите
так от на платформі двері зібрані не
тільки всі дуже багато можливостей
підвищення кваліфікації зараз вже йде
рахунок на 500 якщо я не помиляюсь там
буде інструмент який допоможе педагогу
спочатку пройти саме аналіз наскільки ті
навички ті знання де підвищення
кваліфікації яке має людина уже
вписується у
професійний стандарт вчителя який
затверджений новий із включеними та
дисоціально-емоційними навичками
наскільки це вписується і відповідає
тому що вимагає базової стандарт освіти
у якраз уже в середній старшій школі і
після такого самооцінювання самоаналізу
з одної сторони сама платформа може
рекомендувати що саме є державного для
того щоб закрити от ті речі які
наприклад ще провисають крім того на
платформі двері є можливість працювати в
цьому педагогічному колективу ми
коли її розробляли дізналися про всі
болі які є у педагогів
керівників закладів освіти і побудували
там все так щоб натисканням кількох
кнопочок було зручно зробити наприклад
план підвищення кваліфікації
орієнтуючись на те що вибрали мої
педагоги в колективі так Тобто там є
акаунт закладу освіти до нього
підтягується акаунти кожного конкретної
людини в педколективі і коли людина
проходить оце такий галочковий список
свічок лист оцінювання то ті вподобання
або ті вибори які робить людина
автоматично підтягується у кабінет
закладу освіти і вже заступник чи
заступниця можуть це проаналізувати
скажімо і
система сама згенерує вам план
підвищення кваліфікації на рік у вашому
закладі освіти і скажу ще дві тези
анонсувала три Я за хвилину вкладуся ще
одне Ми стоїмо на тому і багато зусиль
власне в консорті ми про який ви
запитали фокус наш це
розвиток соціально-емоційних навичок
оскільки нуш переходячи в середню старшу
школу
максимально спирається і потребує
наскрізного розвитку цієї компетентності
і в педагогів і інтеграції в ті предмети
які викладаються не говорячи вже про
окремий предмет то наш фокус у консорці
між саме На цьому Ну і третій компонент
- це навчання піртопір ми вважаємо що
найкраще можуть поділитися досвідом самі
педагоги власне всі наші програми на
цьому і побудовані щоб навчити якесь
коло амбасадором амбасадорів дати їм
прокачати певну навичку і вони б уже
самі як педагоги практикують чи могли
передавати і далі Дуже дякую З нами
онлайн Жанна севастянова з британської
ради Україна ви з нами Жанна
Так так я тут Вітаю вас Я вам скажу що
для мене було Сенсація Коли я
побачив що ви вийшли з зони комфорту і
окрім того що ви на той час пропонували
далі пропонуєте вчителям англійської
мови
зробили таку виразну пропозицію для всіх
зокрема щодо
щодо ключових вмінь так здається це тоді
називалося І також
наставництва ментаренко я хотів би
дізнатися наскільки це все актуально на
сьогодні і чи є у вас оновлена
пропозиція яку ми могли б запропонувати
нашим пілотувальникам
пілотувальникам на дру- в другому циклі
базової освіти
перш за все хочу сказати що мета наших
освітніх проектів підтримувати саме
реформи освітньої в країні і пропонувати
експертизу яка є в британської ради тому
ми були дуже щасливі долучитися до
реформи нова українська школа і тоді
допомагали
тренувати агентів змін і також
запропонували програму підтримки
програми професійного розвитку для
вчителів
дуже щасливі були запропонувати Цей курс
і коскілси ключові уміння який на
сьогодні
інститути післядипломної
педагогічної освіти втілюють і мають в
себе в
запропонувати для вчителів себе в
розкладі і наша менторська Програма вона
була дуже успішна ми її пропілотували
але на жаль з початку
повномасштабного вторгнення в Україну ми
трошки призупинилися з цією програмою
саме тренування менторів але я знаю від
вчителів які сьогодні приїжджають до нас
на
тренінг навчання та викладання у
складній часи що вони продовжують школах
проводити цю програму тому буде цікаво
далі поговорити про неї і проговорити
про те як можна її можна бувати для
всієї України
А скажіть трохи більше про те що ви
щойно згадали про навчання в складній
часи це курс який ви пропонуєте вчителям
розкажіть про це Так це цей курс
з'явився у нас як результат
відгуків із зворотнього зв'язку з
вчителями які під час початку війни
знаходилися на нашій платформі три
тисячі вчителів ми їх опитали що можливо
їм буде потрібно що ми можемо допомогти
їм у той час розуміючи що вони тримають
освіту незважаючи на те що йде війна і
намагається допомогти своїм дітям своїм
учням у школі і більшість з них сказали
що вони не знають і трошки розгублені як
саме допомогти дітям як саме допомогти
учням у класі що як побудувати заняття з
учнями і тому британську ради
нас є така експертиза тому що в нас був
розроблений такий курс і він
пропілотований пройшов дуже багато
випробувань імплементації в інших
країнах і працювали з різними країнами в
яких були конфлікти І ми його адаптували
і запропонували нашим вчителям але
оскільки Цей курс такий трошки знаєте
розмова йде про травму і він
емоційний дуже тому ми цей курс
запропонували очну і зараз пропонуємо
вчителям які можуть до нас долучитися
приєднатися до нас на триденний курс ми
проводимо його у Польщі і маємо дуже
гарні відгуки і просимо всіх вчителів
ділитися з своїми вчителями в школі про
те чого вони дізналися головний фокус
тут на тому як саме спланувати за няття
як саме висвітите які можуть бути такі
дуже
важкі питання Які діти можуть піднімати
на заняттях а також
вчителі говорять що в них дуже багато
внутрішньо переміщених учнів і вони
розгублені як з ними працювати Тому цей
курс показує як саме можна побудувати
навчання і урок з англійської мови в
нашому на нашому прикладі щоби залучити
дітей до занять і обійти ці гострі кути
під час обговорення
Дуже дякую Дуже дякую вам за те що ви
робите І за вашу відкритість
продовжувати цю нашу спільну справу з
впровадженням нової української школи
колеги наш час добіг до кінця У нас тут
вже нулі на екрані і
8 хвилин по п'ятій тому в нас
залишається інтрига ми не встигли
поговорити про спадок фінського проекту
про ті онлайн нові курси які йдуть в
колекцію асинхронних програм які можна
теж обирати
як до курсову підготовку в нас
залишилася не розв'язаною проблема
взаємодії співпраці а не конкуренції між
третім сектором і системою інститутів
післядипломної педагогічної освіти бо це
теж певний виклик щоб ці крила поєднати
в такому стабільному польоті
і
в нас залишається теж дуже багато
відкритих питань як
як доповнювати оцими фасилітованими
процесами
асинхрон на Цю пропозицію
для того всього щоб це щоб це
узагальнити і звести це до спільного
знаменника ми будемо взаємодіяти і
надалі під час під час керівного
комітету фінського проекту який
передував
наглядові засідання наглядової ради Віра
Рибак яка була тут майже цілий день з
нами запропонувала мені як агентові від
збоку фінського проекту який залишається
в команді підтримки реформ подбати про
той спадок
і я хочу тут представити в залі присутнє
Олена Кузьмінська яка відповідає за цей
Напрямок в команді підтримки реформ
Олена ви тут з нами от Олена дуже уважно
усе записує рідко бувають такі люди які
так чітко все фіксують і в себе в
блокнотику а потім потім З цим треба
жити І тут також присутня Юлія Романенко
яка брала участь в попередній па і ми
будемо зараз
ретельно це опрацьовувати всі ці
пропозиції бо виклик полягає в тому що
по-перше зафіксувати ту
пропозицію яку ми накопичили от через
оцей досвід про який ви трохи почули і
його масштабувати для масової практики
зараз уже в шостому класі але найбільший
виклик це зараз увійти в
Пілот 7 я мушу пояснити колегам з
пілотних шкіл що нас що не дало нам
можливості е-е зробити уже зараз от
наприкінці червня хоча б
ту хоча б тій динаміці як це було два
роки тому тому що ми ще не маємо повного
пакета модельних навчальних програм і ми
розуміли що як ми прийдемо до до ваших
координаторів з інститутів і до вчителів
пілотних шкіл то без відповіді на це
питання ми не зможемо нічого більше
зробити тому ми дуже сподіваємося що це
питання найбли тим часом ми
використали лізується
і ми розуміємо що зараз ви Заходите в
уже зайшли в літній відпустки ми будемо
залишатися на зв'язку з тим щоб
найпізніше в на початку другої декади
серпня тобто ще за
декаду до
серпневих нарад дати дуже чітку картину
яка полягала по тому як на з тих моделях
навчальних програм які на той момент
існуватимуть для 7-9 класу укласти
освітню програму закладу Ну
відкоригувати те що ви складаєте зараз
уже не маючи повної картини Тобто ми
усвідомлюємо
ту в якій ситуації ви зараз у зв'язку з
цим перебуваєте ми знаємо що є кілька
груп авторських колективів які у
взаємодії там між собою в командах
готують оці пропозиції або менш цілісні
і ми Очевидно це і і ці колективи будуть
здійснювати супровід так як це було
усі ці роки На жаль такого випередження
яке ми якого ми досягли
на початок 4-го року навчання Коли ми
там завершували початкову освіту коли ви
мали майже
підручники
на партах
учнів нам тут не вдалося досягти і цей
цикл складний і Тут з'являється нові
вчителі от але спільними зусиллями ми
подолаємо цей виклик Я переконаний Тим
більше що я зараз політична воля і
підтримка нам тут не дадуть схибити
наші очільники Дякую вам колеги за увагу
Я переконаний що спільними зусиллями ми
зможемо все це рухатися далі
[оплески]
Дякую колеги і у нас остання підсумкова
промова від заступника міністра освіти і
науки України Андрій сташківа прошу
ще раз Доброго дня
не був з вами присутній весь час але
Я думав що я буду просто сидіти вони
стояти в кінці вже
не був весь час з вами тут але я в
навушнику слухав трансляцію
було цікаво почути результати я з ними
знайомимося з попереднім
цього проекту але в цілому отримав Дуже
багато хороших позитивних емоцій Я
сподіваюсь ви також незважаючи на те що
вже дуже пізня година відносно але все в
нас получиться Отож якщо взяти те що про
що я мав би говорити я мав би виступати
також на одній з панельних дискусій і
говорити про перспективи
нової української школи і концеп і
бачення концепції старшої профільної
школи адже потім я тоді
узагальню під сумую звертати
сьогоднішнього заходу
Отож я собі тут трошки виписав те що я
би хотів вам донести перше з чим
стикнулися міністерство в цілому при
впровадження реформи нової української
школи Я думаю що ви краще
знаєте ніж будь-хто це як важко
впроваджувати реформу коли є ковід а
особливо коли почалися повномасштабні
військове вторгнення коли тисячі і
тисячі дітей виїхали своїх міст були
внутрішньо переміщеними навчалися за
кордоном І продовжують навчатися за
кордоном коли
діти які зараз відвідують школу
потребують психологічної підтримки про
це сьогодні говорили також але хочу
сказати що
це є окремі напрямки роботи над яким
працює Міністерство зокрема перше цей
Міністерство розробляє на даний момент
стратегію по роботі над окупованих
територіях якщо ви чули Міністерство вже
починає робити
такого Такого сходу свого роду базу
вчителів які готові працювати над
окупованих територіях ми запускаємо цей
проект Скоро вийде постанова Кабінету
Міністрів і це реєстр буде відкритий і я
закликаю усіх хто бажає взяти участь у
відновленні освіти майбутніх де
купованих територіях долучатися до цього
крім того Міністерство стикнулося з тим
що
на даний момент у нас 500 тисяч учнів
перебувають за кордоном і Значна частина
з них хоче навчатися тут в Україні
незважаючи на те що іноземні країни де
вони навчаються відповідно до їхнього
законодавства
спрямовують їх до своєї шкіри але Наші
діти не хочуть втрачати цей зв'язок з
Україною і продовжують навчатися знову ж
таки тут ми
бачимо що будемо розширювати діяльність
міжнародної української школи яка на
даний момент надає тільки певний вид
освітніх послуг але в подальшому вона
буде надавати більш широкий спектр і
інтенсивніше працювати з тими
громадськими організаціями які
відкривають суботні школи в іноземних
країнах а також
повноцінні українські школи
і звичайно ще один елемент над таким
Міністерство освіти зараз працюється
освітні втрати Я мабуть думаю що всі Ви
чули про те що освітні втрати
це є та тема яка надзвичайно актуальна
перше - це ковід друге - це війна і одне
і друге призвело до того що наші діти
відстають
в навчанні з різних причин і до них
треба застосовувати різні підходи
незабаром вийде стратегія щодо подолання
освітніх втрат національного стратегія
яка буде ранковою яка дозволить
розробити конкретні кроки по подоланні
цих освітніх втрат при цьому
Міністерство також вже працює над
конкретними інструментами які дозволять
вчителям в школах
оцінювати ці освітні втрати а також
зразу їх і долати разом з учнями це про
проблеми давайте я скажу що що ми будемо
робити далі Тобто ми знаємо що Які в нас
є проблеми А що буде далі перше - це
що проблеми які виникли пов'язані з
різних причин якби мають різні причини
одне з них це відсутність фінансування
ви знаєте що Минулого року я вже про це
сьогодні говорив на початку нашого
заходу
субвенція на нову українську школу була
скасована сотні тисяч вчителів які мали
прийти навчання не прийшли його
десятки тисяч класів які мали бути
забезпечені новими обладнанням
обладнанням на жаль не отримали його
підручники це це це мільйони підручників
не були надруковані не були доставлені
до шкіл
пілотні школи не отримали ті матеріали
навчальні і я хочу подякувати тим
вчителям які Незважаючи на всі виклики
використовували ті електронні засоби для
друкували матеріали для своєї учнів
залучали батьків до цього для того для
того щоб діти все ж таки
навчалися навчалися повноцінно якісно
Тому цього року
державному субвенному бюджеті субвенція
на нову українську школу знову не
передбачена але
але субвенція буде І це об'єктивно
політична воля на всіх рівнях починаючи
від Міністерства закінчуючи Президентом
України Що все ж таки реформа має
продовжуватися і ті тези які звучать
часто в
в суспільстві про те що ми забули про
нуш там не потрібна це все не так ну ж
буде продовжуватися і буде
продовжуватися логічно послідовно так як
вона була запланована ми
ініціювали відповідно прийняття
відповідної постанови і передбачаємо
субвенція на нову українську школу цього
року повернеться
вернеться до свого існування на жаль на
жаль це треба було робити ще в січні
місяці нова команда Міністерства освіти
якомога швидше намагається прискорити
відновлення цієї субвенції Але
все рівно вона вийде пізно пізно тому що
навіть якщо вона вийде в липні місяці це
вже буде пізно але ми прикладаємо всіх
зусиль і Я закликаю вас також буду
працювати з регіонами з тим щоб ми
використали
максимально ефективно ці кошти які
будуть передбачені Ну що ж будуть
передбачені кошти кошти в першу чергу
будуть передбачені на навчання вчителів
це те про що говорили на попередній
панельній дискусії держава дає кошти
безпосередньо для кожного вчителя нової
української школи 5-6 класів а також для
вчителів пілотних класів тобто ці кошти
будуть
інструмент механізм використання цих
коштів буде передбачений такий що вони
будуть заходити в області для інститутів
післядипломної освіти вони вже в свою
чергу будуть залучати експертів агентів
змін які будуть навчати вчителів
програми зараз розробляються по навчанню
вчителів і програми також розробляються
по ну по навчанню директорів
основні
якби заходи щодо підвищення кваліфікації
ми очікуємо що будуть проведені На жаль
вже після початку навчального року але
все ж таки краще Так ніж взагалі не
проводити навчання друге на що буде
спрямовані кошти субвенції це є
обладнання знову ж таки п’яті класи які
минулий рік почалися нові українські
школі вони не отримали цього обладнання
тому цьогорічна субвенція буде
спрямована і на п'ятій і на шостій класи
нової української школи
перше - це буде мультимедійне обладнання
інтерактивне обладнання друге - це
будуть засоби навчання дидактичні
матеріали
На жаль ми не
державний бюджет не є необмежений і ми
все ж таки мусили змушені були вибирати
окремо конкретні напрямки і будемо
пропонувати Саме ці напрямки кабінету
міністрів профінансувати в новій
українській школі
щодо пілотів щодо пілотів хочу сказати
що бачення щодо облаштування за рахунок
коштів субвенції є значно ширше якщо для
звичайних класів нової української школи
враховуючи обмежений бюджет це тільки
мультимедійне обладнання і
дидактичні матеріали То ми передбачаємо
що Пілот буде забезпечений максимально і
кожен клас який є в пілоті сьомий клас
отримає кошти на придбання і
комп'ютерного обладнання і
інтерактивного обладнання і дидактичних
матеріалів а також меблів тобто
максимально
є бачення підтримати саме пілотні класи
оскільки саме вони є тими лідерами хто
веде за собою всю іншу реформу
і третій напрям який стосується саме
Якраз пілоту це є навчальний матеріал
окрема
будемо пропонувати знову ж таки Кабінету
Міністрів передбачити кошти для
оплати видавництва цих навчальних
матеріалів тобто по тих модельних
програмах яких ви виберете про що
говорив пан Роман
Міністерство буде готове якщо все ж таки
Ну якщо буде прийнята постанова
профінансувати е-е видавництво цих
навчань навчальних матеріалів
я розумію ті виклики які стоять перед
міністерством інститутом модернізації
змісту освіти щодо затвердження
проведення експертизи цих модельних
навчальних програм і свого боку ми
зробимо все щоб якомога швидше вони
вийшли і ви могли вибирати з них і
формувати ті навчальні плани які вам
потрібні
це щодо того як буде реалізовуватися нуш
цього року щодо старшої профільної школи
і перспективи її функціонування Ну ми
можемо всі відкрити закони прочитати як
там передбачено функціонування старшої
профільної школи і тут в багатьох
виникає питання чи дійсно вона так буде
функціонувати з цим самим питанням Ми
вийшли на спільні наради новою командою
Міністерства освіти і зрозуміли що
однозначно відповіді немає
зараз на даний момент як я говорю пан
Роман Шиян уже розроблений стандарт
старшої профільної школи фактично він
е-е ще потребує деякого доопрацювання
але
Міністерство ініціювало залучення більш
широкого коло експертів і ви бачили
Минулого тижня на сайті Міністерства
освіти в засобах масової інформації
появилися
заклик щодо залучення експертів до
в допомозі І хочу сказати що там було
дошкільна освіта середнього освіта
позашкільна
професійна вища то середня школа набрала
найбільший експертів з чотирьох тисяч
які виявили бажання в середню школу
записалися півтора тисячі тому в нас
буде великий Пул експертів які будуть
працювати з і давати свої рекомендації
бачення можливо не всі вони звичайно
будуть враховані але суть ми виберемо і
після закінчення таких консультацій
після опрацювання це більш вузькому колі
в Міністерство до
найближчим часом розробить
концепцію старшої профільної школи яка
буде публічно презентована
крім того паралельно відбувається
моделювання мережі закладів старшої
профільної школи це також важливий крок
для того щоб зрозуміти як буде виглядати
освітня мережа в 2027 році коли старша
профільна школа почне працювати
повноцінно і тут хочу подякувати
ми на це передбачили ну якби залучили
допомогу міжнародних донорів і також з
ними працюємо
це юнісеф і кошти світового банку щодо
пілоту
старшої профільної школи Тут також є
дуже різні бачення і на даний момент
Пілот передбачено старт пілоту старший
профільної школи 2026 році
проте як показує практика пілотування
один рік є занадто малим Тобто ми
пілотуємо фактично не
зміст а пілотуємо тільки форму
організації яким чином це провести тому
що автори які в пілоті автори
підручників Я маю на увазі програм вони
не вспівають модифікувати свої
програми для того щоб повноцінно
імплементувати їх в основному масу в
основну реформу Тому можливо
знову ж таки це буде обговорюватися не
раз з тими експертами які виявили
ініціативу залучитися залучитись до
роботи Міністерства освіти
можливо Пілот старший профільної школи
почнеться 2025 році
і тут я хочу сказати Як вже підводячи
підсумки про те що саме
фінський уряд
зараз на даний момент те про що я
говорила на початку долучається
виявляє бажання долучитися знову ж таки
до підтримки реформи нової української
школи і вже були проведені попередні
консультації Про що говорив пан Роман і
саме пілотування старшої профільної
школи може бути один з них напрямків які
в якому Міністерство освіти і в цілому
України отримає підтримку якщо це все
получиться Ми також Очікуємо на те що
Світовий банк надасть відповідний кредит
і ми отримуємо відповідні інвестиції
також в старшу профільну школу не
забуваючи при цьому про базову тому що
інвестиції в початкову школу в
порівнянні з інвестиціями які потребує
базова старша профільна школа є значно
меншими і нас попереду очікує
надзвичайно багато
важкої
кропіткої роботи для того щоб завершити
реформу ту яку почали ще 5 років назад і
все ж таки сказати що ми її успішно
зробили і думаю що в 2030 році можливо
вже не ми хтось інший буде підсумовувати
інші проекти які були реалізовані
говорити про те що нам все вдалося я вам
Бажаю успіху і слава Україні
[оплески]
Дуже дякую за однеділові слова
тож наша конференція завершилась Дякую
всім за ваш час за Ваш вклад за ваші
думки побажання всім Гарного вечора
дякую